[Musique]
bon bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour ce
Day 4 de la artificielle intelligence
Cup et qu'est-ce qu'on a aujourd'hui on
est à la finale des perdants qu'est-ce
qui s'est passé avant hier on a eu un
match monumental peut-être le match de
l'année on verra mais en tout cas
c'était quand même assez extraordinaire
ce match entre Magnus Carlson et Maxime
Vacher la grave on a vibré jusqu'au bout
et au final
manuscarsen l'a emporté dans le
dans l'armée
il a joué il a joué un match formidable
Maxime il est revenu
à la quatrième partie au score à deux
partout c'était c'était vraiment
extraordinaire vraiment c'est pas passé
loin mais
l'avantage de ces matchs c'est que on a
deux chances donc il a perdu une fois
mais ce soir donc d'abord on a un match
vous voyez on a un looser semi final
donc guirin et polyashi et ensuite le
vainqueur de ce match jouera contre
Maxime va chez Lagrave si Maxime va chez
La Grave l'emporte dans ce match qui
sera en deux parties
et bien nous aurons une grande finale
entre Magnus Carlson et Maxime
machinagrave ou Maxime va chez Lagrave
devant l'emporter par deux fois contre
le
numéro 1 mondial Magnus
Carlsen on va regarder tout de suite on
voit que nos joueurs vous voyez on est
en place à Nice guéri et Yann les
pommiashi sont en place ils se disputent
le droit de jouer contre notre héros
national Maxime vacheragrave qui on a
envie on a envie de le revoir clairement
on a envie de revoir contre
contre Magnus on voit anis guéri qu'on a
pas beaucoup vu cette saison au
Champions il était en général
en difficulté dans ses platines où il a
joué beaucoup de division en deux
beaucoup de division 3 et même je crois
qu'une fois il sait pas qualifié enfin
vraiment ça a été dur mais là il est en
Division 1 et ce ces matchs lui
conviennent beaucoup mieux qu'on vienne
beaucoup plus
à son style que
les les open évidemment il est très dur
à battre un egy et on voit on va
regarder le parcours de l'Escal
donc ça c'est le c'est la revanche
aujourd'hui mais ensuite il a battu
Nakamura de zéro il a battu ma meilleure
offre de zéro et donc il revient fort il
est très bien préparé très dur à battre
bon même si il a eu beaucoup de parties
décisives dans ce dans ce tournoi bon on
voit Yann les pomyachi qui a l'air de
chanter et de danser pas du tout inquiet
Yann par son match mais attention
attention se méfier d'anis
très très dangereux salut à tous dans le
chat n'hésitez pas à nous rejoindre
léger décalage comme d'habitude d'une
minute entre le moment où je parle et le
moment où vous recevez ce flux sur les
internets ah là là là là qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé dans le zoom ils m'ont fait
un sale coup ok on va permuter la vidéo
et ses revenus et ça va pas tarder à
commencer c'est à peu près sûr qu'est-ce
qui se passe là la discussion alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe deux parties 15 +
3 comme d'habitude 10 minutes de break
entre chaque partie et le vainqueur joue
Maxime après un break de 10 minutes et
les parties devraient normalement
commencer on va regarder tout ça ils
sont très au point là les joueurs sont
là
on va masquer les parties terminées
c'est l'heure et normalement quand c'est
l'heure et bien ça commence
on va voir ce que ça donne mais
normalement ça devrait pas tarder à un
problème visiblement
qui a l'air de parler dans là vous voyez
bien en direct comment ça se fait qu'on
voit plus ça pendule voilà voir après
et salut ceux qui nous rejoint à ni
Antoine
g3313 statagé Mick du 44 800 évidemment
j'essaie de suivre un petit peu tous les
chats même si c'est pas toujours évident
beaucoup de ça parle beaucoup sur
Youtube ça papote
c'est très bien c'est très bien
n'hésitez pas évidemment à poser toutes
les questions que vous avez envie de
poser
évidemment toutes les questions
convenables
on se comprend
alors hop là et on est en place à Nice
guéri allez-blanc cette première partie
et c'est une défense pétrole c'est
logique on va voir ce que Aniche nous a
concocté il est toujours très bien
préparé à niche cahier des 7 on est déjà
vu qui est C3 on avait déjà vu cette
ligne avec Maxime je crois que nepo a
joué fouder 6 ici mais il décide de
prendre 5 puis on prend ou c'était pas
qu'on est pot que Maxime avait eu ça je
sais plus comme si c'était
avant de partir c'est toujours dur à
souvenir petit retour vers la Mach4 d'un
F3 et B6 qui peut paraître très étonnant
parce que ça donne un pion mais je
suppose que on fait fou si si et ful
prend à deux ok peut-être en résidu en
demander hier est-ce qu'on utilise les
prépas de championnats du monde
oui vous voyez la prépa de pétrole là
c'est à peu près clair que il
l'utilisant encore il y a des pomyachi
avait fait un gros travail sur la
pétrole qu'il a utilisé au candidat et
qui utilise encore encore maintenant à
Nice guéri qui est un petit peu surpris
est-ce qu'on peut pas le mettre un peu
plus grand Aniche
ou alors ou alors c'est moi attendez je
vais essayer de mettre pourquoi on voit
ça son choix capillaire ah oui oui donc
c'était moi en fait
c'était moi qui le mettais trop bas
ça et comme ça on voit ses cheveux non
plus
il est attentif à ce genre de détails il
aime bien il aime bien avoir l'air
comment on dit il aime bien avoir l'air
alors on va faire ça pour voir
voilà là c'est mieux
ouais
OK et donc Aniche qui joue dans me prend
des 5 fous aussi dans le 4 dans
et on attaque la tour c'est ça sa petite
pointe des 8 mai Yann il dit moi j'ai
tout analysé tu as un pion de plus
certes mais j'ai la colonne j'ai la
colonne des je t'attaque le pion a j'ai
une meilleure structure et j'ai regardé
ça avec mes seconds mais secondant
regardez ça pour moi et je sais que
c'est nul je sais que tu me passeras pas
dans cette variante
donc il est extrêmement bien préparé
comme d'habitude il y a des pomyachi
normalement c'est deux deux joueurs
assez bien préparés quoi que nepo est
quand même
plus aléatoire les pots il y a des
ventes qui connaît très bien il y a
d'autres où il est un peu plus fragile
et joue à quatre années qui protège son
pion
et
voilà donc A4 jouer à 6 jouets à tempo
pour empêcher des full G5 développement
en attaquant la tour et on n'a pas peur
que ce pion on va simplement le prendre
donc il y a un moment ou un autre on va
le fixer avec à 5
et ça semble très très raisonnable pour
les Noirs alors comme dirait que frais
ça les gueries là je sais pas mon cœur
balance
et j'ai pas
c'est pour c'est comme hier soir hier
soir avec ce match mvl Magnus ou mon
cœur balancé mais pour des raisons
complètement différentes dans ce cas là
j'ai des mauvaises expériences avec les
deux donc je sais pas
je sais pas pour qui pour qui être
espéré
je sais pas je trouve que
allez petite préférence quand même pour
pour guérir au niveau du style au moins
je comprends tout ce qu'il fait je
devine c'est cool
donc disons que d'une manière
stylistiquement je suis beaucoup
beaucoup plus proche de guéri un épaule
je comprends rien ce qui fait à chaque
fois il joue à toute blinde j'aime pas
ça non plus et qu'est-ce qui se passe là
il va encaisser le pion alors je vous
disais on va voir s'il va me faire
mentir ou pas mais je crois qu'on va
encaisser ici et oui pourquoi pas on
remercie évidemment j'en profite que ça
soit ce début du show pour remercier nos
amis évidemment de rings regardez qui
contrôle la qualité de l'air manuscrit
vous pouvez voir les chiffres plus tard
et évidemment opéra le meilleur
navigateur au monde
ainsi que secrète Lab on attend toujours
qu'il m'envoie une chaise mais on les
aime bien quand même
et oui c'est son des chaises haut de
gamme à 5 puis on prend un 5 tours si
vous télétravailler beaucoup ça peut
être utile d'avoir des chaises comme ça
pour pas avoir mal au dos tout attaque
le pion et maintenant peut-être je
pensais qu'on le protéger est fou B6
mais en fait son idée c'est de faire
fout à 3 et si on fait le coup naturel
ici qui est tout rose on peut faire
pousser 6 mais il y a fout des 7 donc je
raconte n'importe quoi donc ça marche
pas du tout son truc à Aniche
il va se prendre fou B6 et il a donné un
pion pour rien attention ça va plus on
va passer alors certes il a détruit un
peu la structure mais il a redonné pion
immédiatement c'était pas ça le concept
a priori
c'était du troll au départ le 59 mais
c'est devenu
c'est devenu assez agressif de sa part
donc bah voilà on a on a coupé toute si
du troll au départ c'était plutôt amical
en tout cas en ce qui me concerne
mais ça c'est une escalade un petit peu
on va pas parler de ça
non non il est assez agressif sur sur X
sur Twitter il est agressif au bout d'un
moment au début ça chambre est gentiment
et au bout d'un moment ça s'est mis à
parler un peu plus
un peu plus durement notamment
en gros il accusé la team Carlsen de
faire une tentative de déstabilisation
dernier
il était sérieux avec ça
qu'on essaye de déstabiliser parce que
c'était
selon lui le rival le plus dangereux
pour Magnus bon
des rivals dangereux pour Magnus ces 10
dernières années j'avais pas beaucoup vu
quoi
à part à part car Wana qui est quand
même qui a du Sud aussi son niveau de
jeu qui était pas loin au classement
hello sinon le reste bon ça reste quand
même largement derrière alors sur des
périodes de grosses formes comme Maxime
en a eu hier Maxime allait compétences
pour battre Magnus quand il est quand il
joue son hey game on l'a vu hier il a
joué vraiment
de manière ça faisait longtemps que je
l'avais pas vu jouer comme ça là il
s'est vraiment et c'est vraiment donné
Maxime et c'était un gros match
mais effectivement quand Magnus est dans
cette forme aussi c'est compliqué bon ça
c'est joue à rien évidemment le gain de
ce match joue Maxime tout à fait et il
joue il a joué très logiquement les pots
sans se casser la tête fous ces quatre
on attaque la tour et Tour Eiffel 8 en
attaque ce pion sur tout reprend à 5 il
y a simplement il y a simplement pour
prendre le 5 regardez les petites
embrouilles menaces parce que X7 ne
marche pas on va montrer pourquoi le
fameux mat du couloir
donc tu reprends à 5 je suppose que
l'idée c'est de faire fouter 6 et
surtout un en fait on reprend le 5 c'est
encore plus fort comme ça on a tout 8
qui arrive il fait foie F4 indice
faut quand même protéger spion
je vois pas vraiment d'alternative très
sérieuse pour Anish mais qui prend son
temps il a bien raison
c'est le début de partie c'est une
finale on a on a 15 minutes quand même
au début
mais Gustave s'en a été son second an
oui mais bon
il fait ce qu'il veut
tout à fait
oui Maxime ancien top 2 on rappelle tu
as raison j'aime visigo numéro 2 mondial
en 2016 avec 2820 donc effectivement
pas tout à fait au niveau de Manu mais
pas loin pas loin c'est clair c'est
clair c'est clair c'est un top
top 10 mondial depuis une dizaine
d'années
Maxime en océan entre la deuxième et la
dixième place alors là il a un petit
coup de mou mais je pense qu'il va
revenir
salut stunt
il Copat et qu'est-ce qu'il a fait mvl
il a fait
il a fait il a perdu il a joué un match
héroïque de partout on le rappelle
Armageddon avec des enchères qui nous
ont un peu surprises mais en tout cas
personnellement qui m'ont surpris
c'était
8 28 que je dise pas de bêtises soyons
précis soyons tatillons
alors soyons tatillon quels étaient les
enchères hier c'était 10 16 pour Maxime
Vacher la grave
et 8 28 pour manuscarsen sachant que les
Blancs ont de toute façon 15 minutes et
ils sont dans l'obligation de gagner et
donc on fait les enchères et enchères à
plus basse ramasse quasiment les Noirs
choisis si elle veut avoir les noirs ou
pas avec ce temps-là et donc 8 28 contre
17 donc quasiment 2 minutes d'écart
c'est assez rare quand même à ce niveau
là mais la fatigue et tout ça moi je
pense que c'est une bonne enchère ce
qu'il a fait Maxime c'est pas ça le
problème
je pense que c'est très raisonnable avec
la fatigue et tout ça
10 16 déjà c'est un gros handicap 5
minutes non c'est parti
donc voilà tech fraise quand il joue à
division 2 ou la division 3 je parle de
moi la troisième personne mais du 11-30
on est aux alentours ce que j'ai dit on
est entre 11 et 12
voilà c'est c'est quelque chose comme ça
donc
parce qu'il y a la fatigue ça se termine
par une gaffe et même la dernière fois
j'ai eu les Noirs donc vous rendez
compte le type en face il avait j'ai mis
11 30 il a mis 12-50 un truc comme ça en
bref il a pas envie d'avoir les noirs
ok intéressant
oh là là doucement
est-ce qu'on connaît les nouveaux
seconds Maxime on connaît le nouvel
entraîneur et le chat va te le dire
évidemment
est-ce qu'on verra là la fine mousse
est-ce qu'on verra la prochaine big up
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas c'était très
sympa ce truc de eSport donc c'était
très sympa donc pourquoi pas si je si je
suis à Paris pas loin de chez moi en
plus donc ça tombe bien et l'ambiance
était très sympa j'ai vu on peut mettre
des des noms sur les sur les pseudos des
visages des noms des visages sur les
pseudos et donc c'est assez sympa
de faire ça il faisait très très chaud
sous les
sous les sous les projecteurs donc
c'était c'était dur mais belle
expérience c'est et
ambiance très sympathique on se retrouve
un petit peu comme dans un tournoi mais
où on joue sur un ordi donc
c'est un côté évidemment très très sympa
et très très novateur et je pense que
c'est ça pourrait être
ça pourrait être le futur en imaginant
un eSport par exemple à Paris à Berlin à
Londres voilà faire ce grand genre ces
tournois là un peu mixé où on est en
format hybride
format hybride moi je trouve ça très
bien
il faut avec des arbitres dans chaque
salle voilà bravo bravo chat
qui a su répondre à cette question
confidence mais ça reste entre nous bien
évidemment qu'est-ce qui s'est passé il
a joué fou B6 attaque tour à 4 alors sur
fou B5 je suppose qu'il voulait faire
tomber 4 ok mais puis on prend F4 pour
prendre ces quatre et tu reprends le 5
toujours la même arnaque il faut elle
s'étire on reprend et bien il est très
bien il y a une éponyashi il est
certainement pas moins bien il va jouer
roi faim faut faire attention à tourner
deux non ouais fin va parce que autour
des deux il y a faux H7 maintenant et
c'est les blancs qui sont bien là
c'est fait avoir roi F1 jouer par nice
guy avec Anis qui est bien c'est que je
devine je devine 8 coups sur 10
9 coups sur 10 même
ouais c'est le pari de temps avec les
Noirs mais la variante turbule dans
laquelle il est rentré qui a
scelarmageddon ouais aussi turbo nul
c'est une caravane archi compliqué
c'est pas turbo nul bon après bravo à
Magnus aussi qui a su qui a su élever
son niveau de jeu pour l'Armageddon je
jouais très vite c'était assez
impressionnant ces joueurs ils sont
vraiment très rapides
ouais donc on a c'est Laurent Blanc
voilà
bon ça doit être nul les blancs les
noirs ont passé éloigné mais ils ont des
pions doublés ici donc ça compense
à peu près
à peu près c'est à peu près à peu près
équilibré
tout 8
tours 2 on protège tout menacé quand
même de peut-être pas F5 tout de suite
parce qu'il faut des cinq échecs mais en
tout cas on n'est jamais trop prudent
comme dirait Aniche
voilà niche ça va faire nul il se bat
pour la nul hein clairement parce que ce
pion a est quand même un vrai élément
pour les noirs
ouais ouais il a il a il a il a une
structure exception isolée mais déjà
il a quand même c'est lui qui a pu
repasser donc c'est lui qui a des
chances
c'est pas très grave cette mauvaise
structure parce que finalement avec les
Blancs on peut pas se créer un pion
passé ce pion est faible mais au pied on
le donnera par exemple sur je sais pas
je vois j'essaie des trois je fais 3 par
exemple puis on prend mais voilà j'ai
donné un pion mais c'est pas très grave
encore une fois
on peut assez vite se refaire
et on a ce pion passé à qui peut jouer
des tours voilà mais en vrai en vrai ça
devrait faire mieux non c'est pas tu
piges pas qui est le qui est le nouveau
secondaire du coup
François Hollande
et pourquoi pas
c'est Laurent Blanc c'est le président
non mais on sait pas on ne sait pas
on ne sait pas on va voir quand c'est
que Maxime
va nous le dire ou pas et dans
magnifiques
online et joue moins donc non là pour
l'instant c'est à l'arrêt depuis le
début de l'année avec Magnus à 10 ans de
bons et loyaux services enfin de bon je
sais pas mais de loyaux ça c'est sûr
plus de match ça devient moins
excitant il joue il joue aussi
[Musique]
il joue aussi beaucoup moins de parties
classiques même si il va jouer la Coupe
d'Europe mais c'est pas tout à fait
pareil le Qatar master aussi mais
ensuite je sens qu'il va faire une
grosse pause il a dit
alors quels sont les conseils pour
commencer les échecs je dépasse pas ici
c'est en fait des puzzles rush chers
amis de la tactique c'est ça mon conseil
tactique voilà j'aime visigo tactique
tactique tactique déjà tu vas arriver à
10002 ça va aller mieux
tactique que ça
pour l'instant pas que ça mais fait des
choses qui t'intéressent déjà mais
tactique des exotiques du puzzle c'est
pas mal
tu te prends un abo sur cheescom tu peux
faire des puzzle rush toute la nuit
toute la journée
sinon je crois que c'est limité
ça c'est pas Zaki Brown
c'est facile il a quand même une très
belle carrière Maxime faut pas oublier
magnifique carrière
c'est déjà pas mal franchement alors
effectivement
pas de match champion du monde ça aurait
été mérité match du championnat du monde
mais ça ça se joue à des détails ça joue
à tournoi arrêté en plein milieu
un des candidats ou on m'enlèvera pas
mais vous pouvez ne pas être d'accord
mais en vrai
si le toit continuait en 2021 en 2020
moi je voyais bien Maxime
et donc voilà l'histoire était
différente après évidemment qu'il était
pas favori dans le match contre Magnus
mais quand même c'est déjà un match
champion du monde et puis il pouvait
gagner
donc il était quand même pas loin alors
après de dire oui
il a choisi le mauvais entraîneur bon
moi ça me semble un peu délicat ou alors
dire Freyssinet un super entraîneur
parce que Carlsen a gagné tous ces
matchs champion du monde oui ça me fait
plaisir mais bon
disons que si j'avais pas été là
peut-être qu'il aurait
peut-être qu'il aurait gagné quand même
ouais c'est ça sprint de problème tu as
pris l'abonnement non c'est puzzle rush
fait des puzzles rush spring de problème
ce qui te fait le plus marrer
mais fais ça fais ça tu vas voir
alors fais ça et d'ailleurs un conseil
pour tous ceux qui sont à moins de 1000
qui galèrent d'abord de la tactique
après on discute
il y a aussi une chaise qui est pas mal
hein une chaise qui fait partie du
groupe jescom qui était de
une propriété de Play Magnus alors
un tournoi M6 ici c'est l'intelligence
artificielle à votre service c'est à
dire qu'est-ce que ou là ça a déjanté
qu'est-ce qui se passe vous mettez
toutes vos parties jouées
et ça vous donne des exercices en
fonction des de vos points faibles et
c'est intelligence artificielle qui qui
gère le truc donc c'est pas mal fait ça
vaut c'est 10 balles l'abonnement par
mois je crois ça vaut le coup
franchement moi je pense que d'ailleurs
c'est pas dire que je le dis mais en
tout cas quand on va montrer ce truc là
même à l'époque où on n'était pas encore
où le groupe les Magnus n'était pas
racheté par cheescom
j'allais dire moi-même chaise pour moi
c'est celui qui a le plus de potentiel
c'est le meilleur site qu'on a
parce que l'intelligence artificielle
évidemment
et du rabattre et voilà donc ça c'est
sympa comme comme fonction
donc n'hésite pas ça c'est mon deuxième
conseil après prendre un coach
évidemment
ça se trouve alors que tu vas me
demander qui j'en sais rien franchement
mais déjà les tactiques arrivé à 1000
sur chaise comme ça sert à rien un coach
tu as pris l'abonnement mais je vois pas
le puzzle
moi je l'ai en deux clics allez à la
pause on va c'est dans quoi
c'est un problème
ça existe plus
problème sprint de problème problème du
jour
dans la barre si on cherche puzzle rush
c'est quelqu'un peut lui dire bataille
de problème
sprint de problème je pense de problème
les ouvertures ça sert à rien
jusqu'à un certain niveau évidemment que
ça sert mais jusqu'à 1500 ça sert à rien
et bien sûr je suis bol est super
évidemment c'est des fous c'est des fous
pour l'auteur c'est pas marrant parce
que
c'est pas marrant parce qu'ils sont
tatillons nos amis de chez veulent donc
machin qui a joué ça la ligne de leur
dit que tu as pas vu
donc en vrai c'est hyper bien fait les
trucs assez bol tu es obligé quand tu es
auteur parce que il vérifie un contrôle
de qualité qui est quand même assez
incroyable
donc n'hésitez pas ouais puzzle rush
c'est vraiment
up puzzle rachetable c'est aussi très
bien ouh là j'ai coupé Yann en fait
je vais mettre Yann en plus grand parce
que là on voit que ça bouge
et ça va faire mieux j'ai l'impression
pourquoi j'ai coupé moi comme ça
il a une belle fenêtre en plus
son truc j'ai coupé à Nice j'ai pas
coupé
ça va
et Yann et c'est mimique
ouais Maxime joue le vainqueur de ce
match
et donc comme d'habitude à droite vous
avez la position à je parle pas trop
d'échec parce que c'est fou de couleur
opposé ça quand même c'est vraiment nul
vous avez le chéquier où je fais des
flèches
j'explique pourquoi vous décède pour
contrôler la case à 4 et en bas vous
avez le direct vous pouvez faire à votre
rythme donc voilà les deux échiquiers
c'est fait exprès
ouais non Bacro super joueur évidemment
super joueur est très certainement moi
j'en sais rien si c'est un bon entraîner
ou pas tous les tous les grands joueurs
sont pas des bons entraîneurs faites pas
dire ce que j'ai pas dit
mais en tout cas il y a pas de raison de
penser que c'est pas un bon entraîneur
enfin j'en vois pas en tout cas
peut-être que peut-être qu'il y en a
mais a priori c'est plutôt oui c'est
plutôt à mon entraîneur
alors
houlà là là ça tout est changé donc ça
va faire nuit qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
roi de Tours FC soit il pouvait pas
faire grand chose pour ces 6 évidemment
et là ça va faire nulle facile on met le
roi des trois le foin à 4 le pion F3 et
moi niche il va pas la perdre celle-là
bon nul dans la première et c'est pas
passé grand chose mais écoutez moi je le
mets là parce que la niche il va pas
perdre cette position je vous le
garantis
donc nul on appuie et il y a des
pomyachi aura les blancs dans la
prochaine
je peux vous garantir que ça va faire
nul dans les prochaines secondes
on aura une petite pause de 10 minutes
c'est pas foufou là cette première
partie c'est vrai qu'on a vécu beaucoup
plus intensité
hier mais bon c'est comme ça parfois ça
arrive
ça sera en 4 1 2 le match de Maxime en
deux parties une fois qu'on est dans le
braquet des perdants c'est toujours en
deux parties
ouais alors le Roi peut faire tout le
tour d'échiquier ça change rien on fait
un coup droit F1 ça n'a pas de sens
regardez le braquer il est là dès qu'on
passe dans ce braquet là dans le braquet
des loosers c'est du deux parties et
quand on rejoint quand on va gagner le
braquet des loosers entre guillemets
c'est dur de dire ça comme ça mais voilà
mvl ou son adversaire rejoindra Magnus
Carlsen
et donc aura
ça sera en cas de partie parce qu'il y a
pas de raison que Magnus joue plus en
cas de parties vu qu'il a gagné tous ces
matchs
donc voilà c'est ça le c'est ça le bail
bon c'est pas trop ce qu'il fait là
il y a des pomiasis on sait pas trop ce
qu'il fait il veut donner le pieu en
message à jamais être pris ce pion il a
pas du tout envie de voir le pur arrivé
à 3
bien sûr bien sûr que Maxime a toujours
son destin entre ses mains tous ces
joueurs là qui restent à Nice guéri yann
est premier hachis Maxime va chez
Lagrave et Magnus Carlson peuvent
remporter le tournoi
clairement il y a
aucun problème là-dessus ah le son est
un peu faible oh non oh non j'ai tout
j'ai tout j'ai tout rectifié là ce matin
j'ai mis plus fort
alors dites-moi
sinon je peux aller encore le augmenter
mettre un peu plus fort peut-être voilà
ça m'agace ce truc quand on me dit que
le son est faible
assez vite qui m'a dit qui et oui
effectivement à quoi s'était sympa
effectivement toujours sympa encore on
est bien reçu on aime les tournois
encore
faut perdre deux fois pour être éliminé
tout à fait
nul le signer
prochaine partie dans 10 minutes
alors on peut passer notre
en break après la prochaine là vraiment
est-ce que le son ça va encore ça
m'angoisse cette histoire de son je vous
raconte pas
je vais mettre encore plus fort là
allez
tu déconnes Jean-Louis Aubert
ça c'est pas marrant
mais
ouais prochaine partie dans 10 minutes
si vous voulez je peux vous faire un
puzzle est-ce que ça va marcher ou pas
est-ce que vous voyez ou pas
où est-ce qu'on peut mettre ça on va
faire ça
parce que sinon
[Musique]
on va voir on va mettre un peu plus
grand ouais je sais comment jouer
on fait 5 minutes elles sont ouais je
vais essayer de vous mettre l'écran
[Musique]
live
j'espère que ça va pas me décaler toutes
les scènes bon je ferai sinon après
bon c'est un peu artisanal mais voilà
vous verrez les positions allez ça part
5 minutes meilleur score 43 ça fait
longtemps que j'ai pas joué
le problème c'est que je suis très très
lent avec la souris
mais voyez là j'aurais dû faire ça
beaucoup plus rapidement
qu'est-ce qui se passe oui il faut
prendre tout simplement
et là j'encaisse la dame
là je fais maths oui le problème c'est
que je suis très très lent à la souris
là je vais encaisser la dame quand même
on va faire ça là on va faire ça
là on va faire ça là on va faire ça
là on va faire ça et ça
et c'est ça le problème c'est que je les
vois tout de suite mais j'ai pas déjà
perdu 30 secondes
là on va faire ça
là on va faire tout reprendre et Tourer
et on va prendre la dame là on va faire
mat
là on va faire ça on va encaisser la
dame
et puis on prend non
là on va faire ça là on prend et on
prend
là on va faire ça ça et ça
là
ça se corse ce qu'on va faire ça ouais
là on va faire ça tout simplement et ça
on encaisse
là on prend et on prend
ah on fait ça ah non
ça a gagné pas ça
qu'est-ce que j'ai foutu
là on fait chèque échec échec et mat
là on va faire a priori échec échec et
mat
là on va faire ça et on va casser la
tour
là on va faire quoi là
comment ça marche cette histoire
on va faire ça et on encaisse la tour
on fait ça
là on fait a priori échec
échec et mat
là on fait ça
là on fait
échec échec et en orchestre le fou là
je crois toujours qu'il y a un piège
mais il y en a pas
ça on fait chèque échec et j'encaisse
ça on va faire
priori cette
et maintenant échec et mat
donc ça on va faire échec échec et mat
ça on va faire échec
échec
et ça et bouffe ici et ça
sur ça on va faire quoi
on va faire quoi sur ça on va faire ça a
priori et on va encaisser le cavalier
sur ça on va faire tout un
et on revient là
sur ça on va faire maths
sur ça
après on va faire ça quand même que j'ai
trop ce qu'on fait tourger un ou dame on
va faire tourner quand même et on va
encaisser
sur ça
tournef 2 je pense merde le coup quand
même
ça y est je suis avec mais ça marche pas
ok ça
vous voyez ça ça devient plus difficile
on fait ça la joue un peu un
donc ici échec on va revenir
gentiment et on a gagné
sur 100 faire ça et sur ça on va
encaisser ici et on va faire mat 37
secondes je joue jamais à ça donc je dis
qu'il faut jouer mais en fait je fais
jamais on va faire ça et on va encaisser
la tour
et la MEC 4 j'ai la petite défense ok là
j'encaisse et fout proche de chèque et
j'encaisse la dame
et là oh ça c'est très connu comme thème
c'est vraiment
alors échec
et maintenant échec et échec et mat 5
secondes échec échec et mat une seconde
nouveau record
BAM
bam bam bam
[Musique]
ouais donc voilà
voilà pour ce
on montre on montre
je passerai pas mon record slider
mon record voilà donc en vous parlant
vous pour vous montrer il fallait faire
trois dans l'autre est-ce qu'on peut
regarder ou pas
tu as moyen par problème et voyez je
suis un peu lent c'est ça le problème
après je suis très très lent la souris
me fait perdre au minimum sur les
meilleurs 30 secondes au minimum
vraiment au bas moi je dis pas ça pour
me
[Musique]
ouais merde là du coup j'ai complètement
le truc est parti
dans tout ça
[Musique]
du coup avec mes bêtises parce qu'en
fait ça se fait c'est sympa
ça se décale bon c'est pas très grave
ah non mais ça c'est n'importe quoi mais
alors
pourquoi j'ai décalé oh quelle andouille
je sais je sais ce que j'ai mal fait ok
j'ai compris
hop là
[Musique]
n'importe quoi n'importe quoi non mais
c'est fait en deux secondes pour la
technicien comme moi
mais effectivement
je crois que c'est bon là on voit tout
on est d'accord
je vais le baisser un peu du coup
voilà
voilà désolé
petit
on va donc les Noirs dans la prochaine
on va suivre de son côté
mais voilà nul dans la première
j'ai essayé avec un écran tactile non
jamais
ah si je clique sur la Croix-Rouge bon
j'irai voir après oui d'accord
en 3 minutes ça serait excellent 48 oui
mais en 3 minutes j'ai aucune chance
j'ai jamais essayé ouais
oui mais c'est trois
c'est le coup oui stéro F5 le coup puis
on prend G4 pour ceux qui ont la ref ou
allez voir roi projet 4 il est obligé de
prendre F4 on prend f43 F2 il prend
l'opposition mais j'ai E5 pour perdre le
temps il jouera deux jours quatre et
c'est moi qui est l'opposition et
ensuite il va d'un côté je vais de
l'autre voilà
non non c'était pas bon ça
donc c'était en fait c'était tout simple
OK
alors
non ça apprend à calculer rapidement
après on peut faire des choses un peu
plus compliquées mais effectivement on
peut faire je pense que dans les
problèmes il y a des trucs plus évolués
problème du jour problème personnalisé
c'est pas mal aussi donc faut aller voir
ça
alors est-ce que ça rejoue ou pas ils
ont l'air non pas encore
ok ça va bientôt rejouer ils ont dit
quoi 10 minutes donc
10 minutes c'était il y a pas de d'infos
mais c'était quand ce truc de 10 minutes
moins d'une minute ok les parties
auraient dû reprendre depuis une minute
donc on va voir là je vois l'écran
d'Aniche et ça a pas repris donc
ne vous inquiétez surtout pas au revoir
rien rater de ce match le temps dis donc
si on a une partie comme ça aussi dans
la deuxième s'amuse pas beaucoup
alors on va voir ce que ça donne
mais pour l'instant ça donne pas grand
chose
rien de la fenêtre ou pas
ok donc on a la partie qui a commencé
avec Aniche qui est noir cette fois donc
on va tourner les chéquier au plat comme
ça et on a une berlinoise quelle ligne
exactement bon c'est un truc après avec
vous français 6 lequel exactement je
vais vous le dire tout de suite mais
d'abord je on s'occupe de chez qui on
est du côté de la niche pourquoi pas
après tout peut suivre le match du côté
de la niche ça m'évite de tourner les
caméras des trois Foussais 5 fous prends
ces 6 dépenser 6 et ces trois aussi
rapidement c'est très très rare parce
que normalement
on a plutôt envie de jouer des cartes
mais on n'a pas envie de trop ouvrir le
jeu non plus pour la paire de fou donc
faut des 6 c'est quand même C3 est quand
même bon une décision
parce qu'évidemment ouvrir le jeu serait
quand même pas extraordinaire
ça va prendre non non non ça reprend à
reconnaître les patterns je suis pas
d'accord Jean-Louis Aubert
et les problèmes s'entend qu'il peut
être pas mal ouais c'est ça ou alors sur
des bouquins aussi des exercices de
tactiques n'importe lequel tu vas dans
n'importe quel boutique tu commandes un
bouquin d'échec sur les tactique niveau
débutant voilà c'est très bien aussi
est-ce que Magnus fait des problèmes
Magnus fait des études
non il se met pas de temps
alors qui BD de jouer ok pourquoi pas
donc il veut venir en C4
mais je comprends même pas comment il
peut être surpris après ces trois
orchidées 7 et certainement coup
principal mais il faut des six peut pas
être une surprise on perd un temps
certes
mais c'est vrai qu'on veut bien
contrôler le centre en jouant c'est si
c'est cinq aussi
et donc vraiment empêcher cette poussée
de des quatre
effectivement les noirs sont quand même
assez assez robustes ici assez solide
il faut aussi c'est normal
et du coup
j'ai déjà joué des trucs comme ça on
veut jouer
on veut jouer cahier des 7 mais on est
en développé notre fou empêché qui est
C4 on peut jouer ensuite F6 et c'est 5
et
Caro parle de résurrection
ouais résurrection le mot est peut-être
un peu fort mais ouais non il revient il
revient à un niveau plus digne de son
talent
clairement
après on a toujours tendance à
surenchérir mais c'est vrai qu'il a eu
une mauvaise période après ces candidats
ratés
c'est la deuxième partie est candidats
où il s'est pas qualifié
en 2021 et donc là ça a commencé une
petite traversée du désert
petite parce que à son niveau
[Musique]
c'est quand même ça reste quand même du
très très haut niveau mais
un peu dur ouais forcément
grosse déception
cette deuxième partie des candidats
ok fougères attaque la dame dame MP3
attaque le pion et attaque ce pion il
décide de donner un niche OK
alors regardons sur ce qui se passe à je
n'aime pas du tout peut-être fou c'est
ça un truc comme ça comment on fait pour
attaquer ce pion des trois rapidement
j'ai 5 et 5 filles qui prend des trois
échecs ça a l'air pas facile pour les
blancs ici
donc B3 n'importe quoi parce que dame B3
n'a pas de sens si on peut pas prendre
le pion
enfin je veux dire la seule
la seule idée de MP3 c'était une double
attaque sur les deux pions
il joue à 3 d'abord OK
alors il faut jouer vite qu'il y a la
mérite d'être d'être esthétique et qui
n'enlève rien qui ne gâche rien et qui
protège en B7 on peut aussi jouer X5
mais le problème de fois 5 il y aura G4
pas sûr que ce soit très bon pour les
blancs mais pas sûr qu'il est envie de
ça aussi
champion du monde de blise 2021 ouais
tout à fait mais bon
ça c'est quand même différent
c'est quand même différent
ça c'est différent c'est un très beau
titre mais
c'est pas une forme globale quoi
salut à tous qui nous rejoignait bientôt
Maxime Vacher la grave qui va essayer de
remporter son match face à Yann n'est
pas bien chez
celui qui a remportera ce match et
voilà il peut regagner sa place pour
jouer
une nouvelle fois contre le grand Manu
le défier dès demain 18h
pour peut-être un match peut-être deux
matchs parce que si on le bat une fois
Magnus lui aussi il a le droit de perdre
deux fois donc il y a une revanche tout
de suite après
ça peut ça peut être un jour très long
pour celui qui est qui gagnait mais
aujourd'hui il a une journée de repos
c'est aussi un gros avantage
ouais bien sûr
c'est vrai qu'il a raté c'est que du
coup il y a eu un décalage dans ce
tournoi à cause du confinement des
candidats donc il y a eu le cycle qui a
recommencé juste après il a raté la
calife au candidat d'après et donc
effectivement à quel âge a qui arrive
ouais changer d'équipe peut-être que oui
ça lui a permis effectivement de se
remettre en question
nouvelle dynamique effectivement
peut-être c'était c'était certainement
le moment ou jamais pour changer
pour tout le monde d'ailleurs moi je
pense que c'est pas mal
de faire des cycles avec les coachs
je me suis jamais fait virer de chez
Magnus je sais pas trop pourquoi
donc à la place de Magnus je me serais
viré
pour justement
entamer un moment ou un autre je sais
pas
disons
peut-être après le match de 2016
match 2016 était dur quoique la prépa
était bonne mais lui lui joue un peu
moins bien donc
2016-2017 ouais peut-être
quelque part par là quoi
pour justement avoir ce nouveau souffle
effectivement nouvelle diamètre mais bon
après tout il gagnait tout le temps
aussi donc c'est compliqué
quand on gagne tout le temps
on n'a pas forcément envie de changer
les choses
tu comprends si 8 en protège et ces
quatre cahiers je vous en parler de
cette manœuvre menace on a pas du tout
peur de rendre de fou parce que ça
rétablit notre structure de pions c'est
complètement ok pour les Noirs moi qui
qui connaissais barinoises
je peux vous garantir que les noirs sont
complètement OK
ouais mais ce cholestive tout à fait et
puis quelqu'un dit je pense que c'est ça
je vois pas je vois pas d'autres
la glue la glue du groupe voilà c'est ça
ouais puis après je suis fait il sait
que c'est une vie je suis français donc
on a une réputation quand même
ma blague dans la dans la team c'est que
j'ai jamais fait grève ils sont plutôt
étonnés
et même une fois la vraie blague en fait
je voulais pas dire mais la vraie blague
c'est que il y avait il y avait un
joueur qui est
un des seconds qui faisait plus ou moins
qui tentait un début de grève
et j'avais
ouais je suis pas très content sur le
coup
bref
j'étais pas très content et du coup ils
ont dit que c'est la première fois qu'un
français fait arrêter une greffe
voilà c'était ça la blague
jamais été sans seconde en principal
j'étais vraiment le deuxième après Peter
ou on est là depuis le début et c'est
vrai que Peter travaille avec lui et
fait que ça en fait moi j'ai toujours
joué à côté quand même effet d'autres
choses donc lui il a il travaille plus
que moi il y a toujours travaillé plus
que moi alors qu'est-ce qui se passe
dans cette histoire qui est C4 cahier
des 7 comme ces deux quais B6 et oui on
force un échange c'est pas mal on peut
pas faire cavalier 3 à cause d'un projet
5 donc on est obligé de prendre et il
prend ici il joue F4 ça c'est d'une
époque ça F400 ok pourquoi pas mais
remarquer si ok bien c'est peut-être les
noirs qui faisait F6 ou F5 F6 d'abord
certainement et ensuite F5 quelque chose
comme ça ou H6 et F5
h 6k F3 F5 elle a l'air pas mal quand
même pour les noirs et on avait
l'initiative donc F4 est logique s'il y
a pas d'embrouille sur le roi au centre
mais ça a l'air d'aller
si vite
qui disent est-ce que je cuisine bien
peut-être ouais
no comment
ouais bien sûr bien sûr
le patron était même pas là
ouais bien sûr bien sûr non mais je
mesure je mesure le privilège donc il a
pris un F4 qui arrive menu le prix
privilège d'avoir été au premier loge de
mâche un peu du monde et d'un tel
champion évidemment 5 matchs
et peut-être le meilleur joueur de tous
les temps donc oui effectivement
énorme privilège je suis tout à fait
conscient de ça je suis extrêmement
reconnaissant
envers Magnus c'est
et sa famille même et son père
qui ont toujours une confiance aveugle
tout à fait le vainqueur de ce match va
affronter mvl et Annie qui joue F5 c'est
tout à fait logique faut H2 et ça a
l'air pas mal déjà pour les Noirs j'aime
bien les Noirs ici
ce que je pourrais pas prendre et jouer
que ces quatre peut-être pour essayer
d'aller chatouiller par là mais pas sûr
mon prix c'est la normale de toute façon
je F4 aussi parfois mais bon il prend on
va pas se casser la tête il va prendre
ici
puis on prend puis on prend peut-être
grand que maintenant on va arriver
connaissez en épaules
est-ce que vous prend un H3 et un coup
tu prends le mérite d'être marrant
grand rock et jouer ok va arriver
jolie jolie coup très esthétique grand
rock va venir maintenant petit ok plus
trop d'actualité et quelque chose comme
fougère
un peu risqué un niche qui prend sa
chance grand ok jouer évidemment
et maintenant il va jouer quatre je
suppose quoi que puis on prend H3 est
toujours pas une menace et non il joue
des cinq Unis ouah il a décidé de pas
Noël pion je t'encaisser un pion et je
le garde c'est ça ça son message
bizarre accepter le pion isolé ouais ça
donne du jeu sur le pion des alors c'est
pions isolé mais avec contre-attaque sur
le pion des voyez le pur en C6 pas en C7
donc il peut pas il peut pas protéger la
structure et donc effectivement faut
prendre des cinq
bien sûr
je vous conseille pas au cardiaque hein
le travail de secondaire on va à une
mauvaise ouverture là on a une grosse
pression pendant les matchs surtout pas
encore pendant les tournois de l'année
ça va mais pendant les matchs a toujours
été marrantes pour imaginer
de proposer un truc qui marche pas de se
faire attraper de pas jouer un coup
pour ça que normalement on faisait
vérifier par quelqu'un d'autre à la fin
on a trouvé cette méthode à la fin à
partir de
2000 pour les deux derniers matchs
disons on faisait cette méthode de on
savait que tout allait être revérifier
par quelqu'un d'autre comme ça personne
ne prend la responsabilité seul et donc
on est moins tendu pendant qu'on fait
nos trucs et quand même c'est mieux
faut prendre H3 servi à quoi à gagner un
pion tout simplement
tout simplement
comment on fait maintenant faut que j'ai
4 je pense qu'il veut faire ouais sur
fou aussi par exemple on va faire puis
on prend si cavalier prend badaboum pour
prendre un 6 c'est ça l'idée
donc là ça doit être le coup ça doit
être dame G6
dame n'importe où protège G7 parce qu'on
en a ces maths et ici là il y a tout
reprend c'est ce qui fait très très mal
donc attention 9 57 contre 6 30 pour un
niche qui se qui est en train de
s'affoler là sur la table donc là c'est
important
non il pouvait pas reprendre parce que
sur 3 puis on prend il y avait tout
reprend cavalier c'est ça l'idée
alors
puis on prend des 5 il faut F5 ou
intermédiaire plus de grandes diagonales
mais apparemment la jauge n'aime pas
assez risqué ce qu'il a fait Aniche et
en plus ça donne vraiment du de
l'attaque l'année pour
la F2 ouais il est en pleine confiance
l'année pour il a l'air content de sa
position
hier content ben ouais ouais c'est un
pion en rapide en plus dame j'ai trois
menaces peut-être même pour prendre un
alcisme menace c'est pas sûr suite dame
G3 dg7
il y a ces quatre aussi et prenez 5 C4
donc il faut prendre du pion
donc ça va plus là pour les pour les
Noirs là niche a été trop gourmand
clairement
comment on fait puis on prend on va
essayer de démontrer l'attaque
madame j'ai trois je crois
tour protège par exemple et maintenant
badaboum pour prendre 6 suite tour à
chin ça va être en quelques coups ça se
voit ça se voit à l'oeil nu
et attention parce que puis on prend
celle-ci c'est une menace donc si on
prend des cinq un coup naturel mais qui
marche pas du tout
ça va être compliqué là pour Aniche avec
ça 5 minutes de moins aussi il passe
sous la barre des 5 minutes
c'est possible qu'on est déjà un
adversaire pour Maxime
attention
pas évident là
mais pour effet des mimiques comme
ikaro c'est sûr 4 vins Anisha faut
s'organiser là faut jouer un bon coup
mais alors j'ai pas du tout la refaire
je sais pas du tout ce qu'il faut faire
honnêtement je vois jamais pris ce pion
quelle angoisse d'aller prendre ce pion
un peu trop disons je dirais
[Musique]
par principe de prendre le pion mais
ouais mais parfois faut s'asseoir sur
ses principes pour pour des raisons
pratiques pour des raisons pragmatiques
pour une position qui est plus facile à
jouer
ah la mvl mvl mvl il arrive 10 minutes à
la fin de ce match donc faut rester pour
ce match
dame 8 jouer
top mondiaux Antilles pour la plupart un
cursus universitaire en général non
pourquoi parce que les échecs prennent
tout leur temps de assez jeune et donc
c'est dur de faire les deux mvl étant
une exception bon il a entre Guille il a
une licence de maths
ce qui est pas ce qui est pas mal mais
bon vu les capacités de mvl ils
pourraient s'il avait fait que ça je
pense qu'il serait
allé plus loin que ça quoi voilà
moi je vois la forme du moment je vois
favoris mvl
voilà largement clairement
qui que ce soit d'ailleurs que ça soit
guéri on est pas
parce que la forme du moment est quand
même
largement
largement avantageuse pour
Maxime
après si deux parties donc ça peut on va
voir comment il va digérer aussi la
défaite contre Magnus qui est quand même
qui doit être un petit peu amer quoi que
il peut être fier de lui Maxime il a
fait un très grand match
donc j'espère qu'il est dans ce
dans ce mode là
en étant vraiment fier de lui fier de ce
qu'il a accompli c'était assez
extraordinaire
donc revenons nos moutons d'un menu de
jouer
sur dame G3 et 6 ça c'est sûr mais bon
vous voyez il a peur du son pion c'est
une preuve ça simplement
ouais je pense que c'est pas idéal de
jouer un match d'abord et un deuxième
match ouais la fatigue la fatigue joue
surtout que les joueurs jouent quand
même beaucoup là depuis le début de la
semaine ça peut jouer un petit peu
la tension
peut jouer sur les joueurs c'est sûr
c'est sûr ces avantages de pas jouer
c'est l'avantage aussi pour ma nu c'est
évidemment de pas jouer du tout
aujourd'hui de pouvoir se reposer
était une proposition du chat mais j'ai
l'impression que ces quatre pions prend
c'était quand même ça le
pas bon du tout
pourquoi la jauge dit Damas 5 ok
intéressant alors que c'était fou pour
ranger cette le coup reprend j'essaie de
me dégager j'ai mis la jauge
et on encaisse ce cavalier sur dame 8 le
bon coup c'est tout simplement de
prendre mais tu aurais qu'il fasse
mais 6 minutes ça y est il a trouvé une
belle solution de M8 super coup de la
part d'Aniche un peu multifonction
c'est que sur pion prendre à me prendre
on va menacer dans le 4 aussi et
attention on peut avoir notre jeu
ça peut être chaud
dame j'ai 3 a été joué il a décidé de
jouer la finale les pots OK et puis on
prend le tour des 6 il est un peu mieux
certes mais bon il faut de mieux
faute de mieux il fait ça
mais c'est tenable pour les Noirs c'est
sûr
et le seul qui se repose c'est
magnifique c'est logique il y a tout
gagné c'est comme ça
c'est pour ça que le match d'hier va
aller très très cher
évidemment
c'est une fille alors
jouer très rapidement sur foo.fr 3
simplement faire puis on prend et tout
reprend F3 on mise sur G6
soit on reprend ses 6 je sais pas tourgé
6 a l'air pas mal quand même
tout F7 on prend 6 quelque chose comme
ça ou alors simplement te repenser 6 8
tours c'est 7 à Tanger 4 oui doit être
mieux
F7 et à tour reprend H6 et c'est assez
difficile pour les noirs
préfère tourger 6 à mon avis la jauge
ok effectivement ça se tient
[Musique]
non parce que alors il doit gagner
tour H4 on verra ça demain je vous
rappellerai les règles évidemment mais
le truc
c'est que demain
admettons Maxime gagne aujourd'hui il
rejoue il rejoue Magnus demain il gagne
dans le match en quatre parties
il refont un match derrière comme les
deux ont perdu il passe tous les deux
entre guillemets dans le braquet des
perdants et donc il joue plus qu'en deux
parties
donc c'est ça le truc parce qu'ils ont
chacun perdu un match
mais oui évidemment gros des avantages
pour Maxime si il doit jouer demain mais
bon aussi c'est pas mal de continuer à
jouer il a joué tout à huile d'abord
faut des quatre et Tours F3 logique on
gagne un petit impôt avec la tour en
s'active et est-ce que Annie je va nous
tenir ça ou pas est-ce que le coup est
tourgé 4G 4 maintenant il y a tout
recettes et si on fait tourger 6
ok tout recettes a pas l'air bon
peut-être te reprendre
certainement tu reprends
alors ton G6 a été joué par les pots
assez rapidement de vin contre 5 17
quand même pression au temps désagréable
pour
pour guéri qui réfléchit à soi protéger
soit Colin un échec d'abord
à mon avis il y a pas urgence à donner
les chiffres je ferai plutôt tout
recettes ici
je n'aime pas du tout mon cou de tout
recettes
bizarre
c'est ça exactement j'assire back
officiel Manu c'est encore une vie ouais
c'est un peu ça c'est ça
qui n'a jamais joué au ping-pong là à
faire ses tournantes
effectivement on utilise notre vie
touriste au F7 en protège sur casse
blanche ici on peut prendre ici ou jouer
ce tour prend
j'ai 4 une autre option pour attaquer G7
mais tour E7 et du coup maintenant
prendre et je suppose et ensuite on va
encaissions c'est pas facile pour les
noirs
c'est sûr
finale difficile quand même pour
guéri mais il a des bonnes chances de
survie parce qu'il reste il y a un
matériel assez réduit alors le problème
aussi c'est qu'il a plus trop de temps
pour qui va essayer de faire fructifier
son avantage au maximum
un maximum rien impossible espérons
espérons déjà il faut on verra on verra
le match d'aujourd'hui
tu reprends H6 jouer
on espère qu'il se fatigue ces deux
joueurs on leur souhaite en armagidon
c'est bon pour nous aussi
attendre un peu plus longtemps pour voir
Maxime mais
Armageddon
ça peut les fatiguer
ouais il y a un
1843 et sans point de plus sur guéri
c'est les lots de chez com en partie
rapide
ouais moi j'ai aussi j'ai aussi un
classement hello j'ai perdu plein de
points à la au dernier tournoi
c'est quasiment en 2007 mais j'ai perdu
beaucoup de points
avec ça donc ça compte quand même c'est
l'eau c'est pas complètement anodin
alors essaie de se défendre on peut pas
prendre le pion parce que elle a tout en
prise et on veut faire ses 5 je suppose
des cavaliers 5
pas évident parce que beaucoup de
faiblesses est-ce que vous prend à cet
échouable non cavalier 5 attaque la tour
attaque le fou
aussi c'est ça
OK
réfléchit non il a joué il a joué ton
jeu de
ok il veut doubler où il va ta question
aussi et je sais 5 rapidement
à Nice il est dans le dur là parce que
il a moins d'une minute contre 3,30 et
il est un peu moins bien clairement
ok il veut installer un cavalier très
actif en Détroit il empêche toujours G6
aussi c'est plutôt bien joué ça il y a
pas de foot français 5 parce que des
trois énorme fourchette
donc ça se défend pas mal quand même
c'est 5 c'est pour activer le cavalier
je vois ces quatre l'idée c'est vraiment
de jouer ces quatre c'est pas de garde
espion et d'en faire une faiblesse c'est
évident c'est du concret c'est pour
pousser le pion
et faire en sorte d'avoir un superbe
caler en détroit qui peut même donner
des bons scénarios au noir des scénarios
extrêmement positifs pas que de nul des
scénarios de victoire
roissez de Kaif en attaque ici en menace
cavalier 1 et je crois qu'on échange les
fous du coup roi B3 ouais là on peut
faire quel étranger on la perd pas
celle-là ça c'est certain quoi la peur
pas essayer de tomber 8 échecs ou tomber
8 échec d'abord roi à 3 il veut faire je
suppose
qui est des autentants parce que sur ton
premier âge 6 donc on peut dévier la
tour autant qu'on veut il faut qu'il
joue un peu plus vite quand même à nice
guy il a 20 24 secondes tomber ces trois
va être joué quoi d'autre
c'est jouer va-t-il faire quelle idée de
l'ambitieux qui a eu des deux pour faire
il y a B3 peut-être sur cahier de
non il va prendre là-bas il va prendre
il va jouer de
je connais par cœur et tout RE 2
j'aurais fait pareil
pour deux et oui évidemment qui fait ça
et B3 C4 il veut tout échanger
moyen de pions mis en sport B4 on peut
même faire tourner en immobilise une
tour
alors dimanche un peu mieux pour les
blancs mais là franchement j'y crois pas
alors pour ces 6 attaque le pion ok on
encaisse on a quand même ces deux pions
qui sont le seul à tout vraiment des
blancs dans cette situation
et la pendule à moins de 10 secondes
pour Aniche il faut qu'il joue beaucoup
plus vite tout le 5
ok
donc là je suppose qu'il a poussé soit
B4 soit C4 B4 il y a 5 qui liquide un
petit peu tout ça
sur ces quatre tours 3
ça se passe bien
la troisième lettre et système rapide au
maximum waouh il a toujours été très
très haut Maxime sur chaise comme
apprento 5 tours G4 G5 et là en rapide à
la faveur de son dernier tournoi archi
réussi là en ce moment playing plus
match évidemment il gagne plein de
points donc c'est pas étonnant de
retrouver la septième place
moi j'ai cette B4
et maintenant ah c'est pas facile quand
même cette position
dans becato F7 pardon tout racisme pour
empêcher justement la tour de venir ici
et comment on fait ici oh là là il a
plus que 5 secondes mais il va pousser
elle est pas facile cette position ça
panique un peu chez anis C5 jouer ton G7
oh mais c'est dur c'est dur ça va
peut-être être perdant
oh là là que c'est dur pour guérir
une peau qui a bien profité là de son
temps son avance au temps pour
capitaliser sur ça
c'est pas quoi jouer à Nice ouh là là
Tour Eiffel
et il pousse tout simplement surtout un
et à faire roi B5 il met la tour
derrière ouais ça c'est un bon mon
système de défense maintenant qu'est-ce
qu'on fait
tourger 6 échec va arriver je suppose et
on pousse à moins qu'on puisse mettre la
deuxième tour par là ah c'est pas si
évident et tous ces quatre ouh ça fait
très mal
ça fait très mal et si on prend on
reprend on arrive en premier à 6 h rose
et 5
c'est cette tour eiffuite mais ça ça va
être terminé roi B6 et ouais on va faire
dames et non et non ça va être fini
abandon de Yann et Premium qui gagne
cette finale de tour bravo à lui
bravo à lui
et il l'emporte
sur le numéro 1 batave
à Nice guéri d'où vient cette réputation
des nuls
ça vient des candidats où il a fait 14
nuls consécutives
ça crée une ambiance quand même
et 1,5 pour Yann les premiers
ici on va retrouver notre ami mvl d'ici
une petite dizaine de minutes on regarde
le bracket et on voit
Maxime machine agraf sera au prise avec
Yann les pomyachi d'ici une dizaine de
minutes magnifique que demande le peuple
ça va être beau
ça va être très très beau
sur ce on va se faire une pause
publicitaire pour remercier
nos différences sponsors
et vraiment on les remercie on les
remercie parce que
parce que sans eux rien ne serait
possible merci notamment
on se retrouve petite pause type
match
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour donc pour ce match
entre Maxime va chier La Grave et Yann
nepomashi qui vient de battre Aniche
Guiri somme toute sans trop de soucis il
a joué vite il a mis la pression dans
son style habituel Annie guéri a craqué
et notre champion français est en place
on va le voir non on va pas le voir il
vient de se lever non on va pas le voir
parce que j'avais mis
et on voit oh mince alors
ah là c'est ballot ça d'accord donc on
va mettre Yann
ici et
on va changer on va changer je suis
désolé
je sais pas pourquoi ça c'est décalé
parce que Maxime a dû arriver plus tard
et donc il y a des pommiers il est là
et on va éviter de montrer le chat
de zoom si il y a rien de compromettant
vous en faites pas
on va montrer Maxime avec cette belle
avec cette belle chaise secret Lab qui a
dû recevoir on va changer son petit nom
mvl
et on va surtout remettre les compteurs
à zéro on veut pas voir ça
on va remettre les compteurs à zéro
des deux côtés et il y a une peau aussi
qu'on va remettre à zéro
voilà et on est en place pour ce match
qui se jouera en deux parties
on le voit le vainqueur aura le
redoutable privilège de défier
manuscrite dans la grande finale
donc on va voir tout ça mais ça serait
génial d'avoir un petit un petit
revanche entre un VL et manuscrite
demain 18h
il faut la mériter pour Maxime Vacher la
grave ce sera une deuxième chance mais
ça sera aussi la dernière
plus de droit à l'erreur on peut perdre
une fois mais pas deux non c'est tournoi
ah oui ah oui les chaises secrètes là au
boulot
on en veut tous
pourquoi je fais peur
dans les variantes et tout d'accord bon
on voit Maxime qui est là qui a l'air
très reposé très serein
il est en place normalement ça doit
commencer maintenant mes dépôts
petite banane pour notre ami Maxime un
morceau de banane pour Maxime qui a
troqué son saucisson habituel pour les
bananes et bien
c'est mieux non
ouh là ça y est ils m'ont refait le coup
je connais la variante je sais pas
pourquoi ça se à chaque fois
ah ça va décaler le truc merci
ah bah d'accord
ah bah d'accord il me décale à chaque
fois la petite image
mais voilà on a Maxime
on va essayer de le mettre en plus grand
un peu plus grand Maxime
voilà
on est bien là avec Maxime
ça n'est pas
et ça va pas tarder à commencer je vous
dis qu'il y a les blancs qui a les Noirs
c'est le premier cité qu'elle est blanc
donc là la première donc c'est Maxime ma
chaîne qui va commencer avec les Blancs
c'est aussi simple que ça dans le
bracket on peut aller voir le bracket et
on voit à chaque fois qu'il y a les
blancs qu'elle est noire donc Maxime
aura les blancs pour cette première
partie bon
j'ai pas grand chose je préfère
légèrement avoir les Noirs en cas de
défaite
plus de chance de se refaire
plus de latitude avec les Blancs pour
jouer agressif
on se calme alors là alors là ça sera
mon premier ban
comment je peux faire
alors attends
on va le
voilà
un petit 600 secondes
on parle poliment alors on a le droit
d'être pour Maxime on est tous pour
Maxime ici
enfin
on a même le droit d'être tourné pour ça
c'est quand même c'est plus border mais
on
essaie d'être
en effet
ouais c'est ça
un peu de respect dans le chat
notamment s'il y a des enfants c'est de
parler poliment voilà
loser signifie plus relâché
mais là je suis désolé c'est marqué
comment
loser désolé loser là c'est perdant
là c'est marqué ah oui ça c'est les
anglais alors va dire aux Anglais qu'ils
ont fait une faute ah non c'est dans
notre
titre de
c'est un titre de
alors mince ah j'ai raté le début je
suis désolé
monsieur qui parle pas bien bon c'est
pas grave
e402 ça c'est une des ventes préférées
de Magnus Carlsen
qui se termine qui il a joué d'ailleurs
un champion du monde face à face à
nepomyachi
cavalier
comme ça et oui
et on est un peu mieux parce que
justement ce cavalier normalement est
pas très bien placé mais il se replace
en Russie
et tout va bien
tout va bien pour
qui a trois c'est 6 qui est ces deux
tout va bien pour les Noirs normalement
alors légèrement avantage peut-être
c'est il joue le client à mon avis il
joue le l'Open notre ami Maxime
c'est à dire qu'il veut jouer qu'on
époque qui est normalement
qui aime pas qui aime pas ce genre de ah
oui mdr en finale du loser bracket
il y a cette faute ok je la signale
fu F5 je peux pas le changer je suis
désolé
mais effectivement oui je savais ça
peut arriver une faute de frappe je
pensais plus une faute de frappe qu'une
faute de compréhension
en tout cas
ouais ouais effectivement oui ça a
commencé cet été ça va être compliqué à
suivre mais bon c'est sympa donc c'est
merci de ce témoignage alors cahier des
trois jouets ouais en même temps on sait
pas trop quoi faire et c'est vrai que
parfois on a des idées de pousser un
petit peu à l'endroit en espérant F3 qui
contrôle bien les cases
normalement position légèrement plus
plaisant à jouer avec les Blancs quoi
que là c'est même pas sûr honnêtement
ouais c'est ça il faut l'ennuyer à ouais
une française c'est une sorte de
française d'échange effectivement il
joue à 5 pour empêcher G4 et c'est vrai
que normalement nepo il peut négligent
dans ce genre de position
donc
intéressant le choix choix beaucoup plus
psychologique que technique de la part
de Maxime qui a une très très bonne
technique en finale on a vu une peau
montrer des gros signes de faiblesse
contre contre Magnus notamment en cette
finale roi dame qu'on croit tours final
de tour aussi donc choix psychologique
et je sois très intéressant de la part
de Maxime
pour pas se faire doubler les pions il
va remettre en cavalière aussi c'est
vrai qu'objectivement parlant les Noirs
ont aucun problème
mais voilà on s'envoie pas en l'air on a
une position si ça se passe bien
légèrement avantageuse ou au minimum
peut-être un peu plus plaisant à jouer
je crois que c'est je crois que le
minimum n'a pas été atteint parce que
l'année peau a très bien fait c'est de
voir à la maison mais c'est pas grave on
a une position égale qu'on va jouer et
on va voir ce qui se passe
qui va aller au 3 jouer en touche le fou
ici alors où est-ce qu'on met ce fou
soit on le met par là ouais ça me
semblait mais voyez ils traînent pas un
époux ça rigole pas ça joue vite
peut-être 3 7 là pour reprendre du roi
en D6 ouais c'est jouer très vite
cavalier aussi et le prochain coup on
peut quasiment primov avec les Noirs ici
et c'est vrai que c'est d'une solidité
ça va pas être facile de créer quelque
chose dans cette position pour les
blancs
Maxime vainqueur niveau cam ouais c'est
pas faux
espérant qu'il soit vainqueur tout court
alors est-ce qu'on fait quelque chose
comme tout un fouet fin après tout il y
a une colonne ouverte pourquoi pas
mettre les tours
mais là il a su s'organiser comme je
vous le disais le seul défaut des Noirs
c'est d'avoir ce cavalier qui est en C6
qui sait pas trop quoi faire parce qu'il
y a les pions vous voyez les pions
contrôlent bien le centre et le cavalier
peut pas venir là mais là il a trouvé
une case magnifique pour son cavalier
aussi il connaît tous ses plans il joue
très vite il y a des pomyachi il a eu
dans une partie de match champion du
monde donc effectivement il connaît tous
des finesses de ce genre de position
il n'y a pas de problème pour lui prise
prise c'était PRIMOVE et le cavalier va
venir 6 bientôt
très certainement au prochain coup
comment on va faire avec les Blancs
peut-être un petit coup de H4 pour fixer
tout ça peut-être cavalier F4 aussi mais
Caval F4 attention c'est peut-être les
noirs qui jouent H4 et ensuite j'ai 5 et
ensuite cavaliers aussi
les noirs sont conformes il y a pas de
problème sur ça
peut-être H4 quand même ça me tenterait
mais après cavalier aussi je serai pas
trop quoi faire honnêtement KLF 4 jouait
d'abord ok ok il a pas peur de H4 H4 a
été joué et G3 petit coup
petit coup qui menace de prendre je
pense que c'est une vraie menace après
on peut faire H5 et tour G1 mais de la
pression sur le pion G
si de nul c'est Armageddon direct comme
hier
c'est match en deux parties un partout
on le rappelle le format de nul ou à
partout à partout une victoire chacun
Armageddon 15 minutes pour les blancs et
ensuite système des enchères pour avoir
les Noirs si on met moins de temps avec
les noirs on choisit
on peut choisir d'avoir les noirs ou
d'avoir les blancs d'ailleurs mais en
tout cas on est obligé de prendre le
temps qu'on avait proposé
donc typiquement Maxime qui est proposé
10 16 hier pour avoir les Noirs mais
même Magnus Carlson qui avait proposé
8-28 rendez-vous compte
8 28 contre 15 minutes mais le comme on
dit il est trop hautes c'était à la
possible la possibilité de faire nul si
on fait nul on a gagné
donc un format intéressant avec ce petit
ce petit truc des enchères qui est sympa
les joueurs qui se comprennent pas parce
que Magnus il avait su le truc de Maxime
évidemment il aurait mis 10 15 voilà 10
15 et là à ce moment-là Maxime aurait
pas été très contente parce que dans ce
cas là il était content probablement
d'avoir les blancs
ah ouais bien sûr les joueurs se
préparent alors je sais pas si les gens
se préparent très sérieusement
je pense que certains oui pas tous mais
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
réfléchit c'est ce qu'ils vont jouer
moi je sais même quand je joue la
division 2 ou 3 je me préparais quand
même assez sérieusement
pour essayer des choses voilà pour être
bien après l'ouverture
et pourquoi ce choix de couleur parce
qu'il faut bien déterminer un vainqueur
parce que si tu fais des allers-retours
en permanence
ça va être compliqué on va pas on va pas
s'en sortir du match c'est ça le c'est
ça le souci
on voit le reflet dans les lunettes de
Maxime je sais pas si vous voyez comme
moi mais moi je vois le reflet de de la
position sur ses lunettes
c'est assez marrant
alors fout des trois c'est vraiment pour
avoir la case F5 et vous voyez il a
obtenu un petit truc il s'est un peu
enflammé un épaule il a vraiment poussé
tous ses pions et maintenant fou des
trois on veut la case F5 pour le
cavalier qui est quand même une très
très belle case on sait jamais ce pion
peut être perdu je trouve que les pots
étaient négligent légèrement mais ça
pourrait lui jouer des tours
comment on fait ici avec les Noirs je
sais pas il réfléchi peut-être que G7
pour essayer de contrôler cette case que
j'ai cette me semble être un coup tout à
fait
acceptable pour contrôler cette case F5
ça serait vraiment embêtant d'avoir ce
cavalier qui bondit ici mais après faut
prendre on reprend qu'il y a des trois
on garde quand même un léger avantage
c'est un peu plus agréable à jouer avec
les Blancs ce pion peut être perdu dans
certaines finales de cavaliers comme
j'ai quatre rois G3 donc là c'est les
noirs qui doivent faire attention très
clairement
ah oui il y a pas de garde-fou si on
regarde
[Musique]
un très petit temps oui oui c'est ça
c'est on prend on met 10 secondes avec
les noirs
et notre adversaire et on est sûr
d'avoir les blancs
mais en même temps si on met 15 minutes
avec les Noirs pareil on est sûr d'avoir
les blancs aussi donc fais attention on
va pas le faire trop souvent
vous pouvez aussi faire format Coupe du
Monde oui bien sûr changement de cadence
à être plus en plus vite mais voilà
c'est ce format qui a été choisi pour
qu'il y ait une fin aussi
moi je vous dis aussi c'est les formats
télé
format télé avec un armagidon on est sur
à peu près de l'heure approximatif de la
fin
parce qu'après il y a d'autres
programmes vous comprenez bien on n'est
pas sûr que sur Internet
format télé en Norvège donc Magnus est
suivi dans tous ses tournois 10 minutes
chacun et ouverture qui était pas grand
chose mais là c'est un petit plus si
c'est rien
c'est un petit rien agréable tout est
fuite c'est joli idée de jouer F5
pour contrôler cette case F5 donc
maintenant si on prend on va faire
tourner F5 Roissy 7
pardon et sur quel étroit on va faire
que j'ai 7 pour chasser ce cavalier
mais apparemment c'est pas très bon
d'après la jauge certainement qu'elle
prend pour prendre envisager un petit
coup de tourin et c'est vrai qu'on
aurait la colonne
et toujours ce g4g3 qui peut arriver et
il fait fou F5 mvl
OK
ok intéressant
ouais j'aime beaucoup le
j'aime beaucoup le la position la façon
dont maxime a traité le début du milieu
de jeu qui était en fait une finale mais
en tout cas je trouve qu'il le traite
beaucoup mieux que son adversaire
après est-ce que c'est équilibré
l'Armageddon je sais pas mais en tout
cas ce qui est sûr c'est que les règles
sont les mêmes pour tout le monde donc
peut toujours se plaindre mais en tout
cas à la fin ça revient au même
à 5 attaque le pion
c'est pas du tout des state non
alors là mes chers amis c'est quand même
n'importe quoi mais bon
faut que j'ai 8 et ben ok des trois bien
sûr
en centralise tout ça
Pathé de pièces là
qui est pas très impressionnant il
voulait vraiment pas prendre en F5 il a
et ce pur H3 en prise qui voulait pas
faire ça n'est pas il est beaucoup moins
bien là beaucoup c'est peut-être une
exagération mais en tout cas il est
moins bien ça c'est certain
oui oui tu peux faire il y a des
stratégies aussi même pour la main c'est
sûr
après c'est vrai qu'on était habitué à
voir des enchères très très basses
notamment dans les match Nakamura
Carlson Magnus qui Molly pas qui
considère vraiment que 8 entre 8 et 9 il
fait toujours des enchères très très
basses
on essaie en attaque plus ou moins ce
fou alors que c'est bizarre
que c'est bizarre ce qu'il fait ce qu'on
peut pas centraliser une détour là
on donne ce fou c'est pas très grave
parce que sur ton rachat cavalier prend
on va pouvoir très certainement
pénétrer par là
quelque chose comme ça ça a l'air pas
mal quand même en esquet c'est 5 en
menace de doubler les noirs sont quand
même pas terrible ici
non là c'est pas l'Armageddon c'est la
première partie
c'est la première partie
le début du milieu de jeu qui était en
fait une finale ben une finale parce que
une filiale parce qu'il y a eu ça
une fois qu'on fait d’âme prend un deux
considère que c'est une finale mais
c'est une finale soft c'est à dire c'est
une finale où il reste quand même
beaucoup de pièces il y a que les dames
qui ont été changées mais je pense que
sur le plan de la
de comment on doit appeler la chose je
pense que c'est une c'est une finale
donc début du milieu de jeu au final
voilà
qu'est-ce qu'il a joué Maximilien je
vais vous prendre ces trois points et G4
un joli vraiment à lui enfermer toutes
les pièces intéressantes ce coup de
Maxime
attention à F6 j'ai pas la rêve sur FC
mais échec a l'air fort échec Roissy 7
ou 1
c'est quand même délicat peut-être
truqué c'est 5 rois C8 quand même comme
ça surtout ouais on menaçait pas tout
recettes directement mais tout quand
même
ça paraît très très compliqué
pour les noirs qui est j'ai 4 You F6 un
époque et c'est 5 jours et la vente que
je regardais roi C8 évidemment pour pas
se mettre dans les échecs après tout
Reut normal tout un jouet
ça joue vite mais pas trop de la part de
Maxime le champion français qui gère son
temps
vraiment de manière impeccable
bravo lui il y a moyen de voir le bilan
à la fin de partie à la fin ouais on
pourra regarder si vous voulez
ça joue fort là pour l'instant ça c'est
sûr
Tourer menace déjà
première menace si on reprend tout
recettes échec et on ramasse le pion
tout recettes et aussi une énorme menace
donc il faut l'appareil
il est pas bien les pots j'ai
l'impression peut-être baisser quoi
d'autre
Maxime archi concentré B6 et sur cahier
des trois on fait aussi quelque chose
comme ça
je vois pas grand chose d'autre
honnêtement
pas très plaisant cette position
tour H7 waouh
protège ici mais c'est une gaffe d'après
la jauge
ça laisse le cavalier ici alors
qu'est-ce qui se passe tout recettes
cavalier F5 c'est ça l'idée
c'est l'idée
on peut en mettre une couche
7 c'est vraiment étrange je devine pas
un coup avec un épaule
c'est quand même bizarre
toutes les mimiques de la tête c'est
compliqué
non je crois que c'est la limite de 15
minutes on peut mettre de 0 à 15 minutes
cartouches
pour la dent je pense pas qu'on puisse
mettre deux armes sinon on s'en sort pas
c'est 14 peut-être 14509 le minimum je
sais pas
alors
comment on fait
pour Maxime je la vois pas la solution
je vais tricher on le meilleur coup là
vous devinez jamais c'est à 4
mais tous deux tours 2 a l'air pas mal
quand même pour deux mais il y a B6 en
fait A4 qu'elle était l'idée on va
regarder un 4 comme ça sur B6 qui va
falloir faire tôt ou tard on va faire
cailler des trois et ensuite on va faire
à 5
la profil accès à son max tour 2 V6 kd3
jouer
mais maintenant vous aussi c'est pas du
tout la même sur fosie si on avait A5
tout à l'heure
on va t'expliquer dans le chat ta petite
finale et la grande fille ça fait 20
fois que j'explique ça fait beaucoup de
fois que j'explique désolé je vais je
réexplique à chaque break donc là on se
concentre sur la partie
alors qu'il y a des trois et maintenant
vous aussi ça va être joué très
certainement mais il doit avoir peur de
toi enfin en tout cas il doit considérer
tout droit peut-être 3 17
on n'aime pas ça quand même
et on voit des pots qui est quasiment
tous au niveau du temps
c'est pas du tout
son style on l'a vu tout à l'heure il
joue beaucoup plus vite peut-être à 4
maintenant pour faire à 5 et à 4 jouer
par mvl il est en grande forme mvl voit
les coups de l'ordi sur A5 je pense
qu'il veut faire B4 et soit on prend et
puis on prend et ensuite on sera un pion
passé soit on laisse prendre mais à ce
moment là il y aura une cassée 5 qui
sera magnifique pour les blancs
donc c'est complexe pour les Noirs ici
à 4 à 5 a été joué B4 va venir c'est
quasi certain
c'est l'idée
c'est je vois pas vraiment d'autres
raisons d'avoir joué à 4 à 5
et il comprend pas Maxime
et va être joué
quasi certainement
et c'est jouer
mvl en grande forme
comment on fait maintenant je sais pas
il y a pas pu rater mes pots
mais franchement
c'est pas le problème de pas rater
ouais et là comment on fait c'est très
embêtant tout simplement
allez mvl laquelle position et qui est à
tous autant
donc très bien très facile beaucoup plus
facile à jouer pour les blancs et un bel
avantage
que demande le peuple devant autant très
légèrement 5 secondes
mais c'est sympa quand même
comment il va faire et choupi on prend
mais ça crée potentiellement et puis on
passait j'aurais pensé à primov c'est
prendre ouh alors là j'ai pas eu venir
celui-là ah sur pion prend il y avait
aussi c'est ça
ah oui j'avais pas vu ce léger des
détails donc il prend il est obligé de
prendre du cavalier ok ok ça change des
choses quand même j'étais un peu naïf là
il veut quand même faire à 5 et ouvrir
cette colonne à
faire passer cette tour
et oui oui j'avais raté ça quand même
c'était pas non plus aussi évident que
ça de jouer à 4 ouais donc ça ça
renforce un peu plus mon jugement de
Maxime en grande forme parce que à 4
était du coup pas facile si on est
obligé de prendre en B4 du cavalier
donc clairement
Maxime qui pose un maximum de problèmes
à dépôt il peut pas jouer tour à 8 parce
que le pion F6 est en l'air
et donc il y a un problème de
[Musique]
il y a clairement un problème de
coordination regardez ce pâté de pièces
ça va pas du tout s'il faut aussi ça 5
là on ferait même ça je crois
et ensuite tour à 7 tours 7 terminaux
donc ça va pas du tout
ça a pas du tout pour une épaule
il a joué ces 5 des pots
ok je vous dis ami comme d'habitude
alors est-ce qu'on fait cahier des trois
ou est-ce qu'on prend ma board
au feeling ah oui au feeling j'allais
dire on fait qu'il y ait des trois mais
en fait de problème de ça c'est qui a pu
en prendre puis on prend et cavalier
aussi
alors ça a pas l'air terminé
certainement à 5 et c'est vrai qu'on
ouvre ou tomber deux par exemple
attaque B6 c'est encore chaud ok des
trois jouets par mvl assez rapidement
puis on prend puis on prend attention
menace tourbé deux maintenant et ça peut
être très cher si on perce le pion parce
qu'après c'est c'est tout de la petite
famille qui est perdu
il est très très bien mvl et il pourrait
déjà prendre la tête dans ce match et
prendre la tête c'est une sacrée option
vu que c'est en deux parties
va être joué à mon avis tomber deux pour
faire ton plan B6 ça a l'air tellement
naturel tellement logique
et tomber de jouer rapidement il a bien
raison la maxime il y a plus trop de
réflexion à avoir tellement les coups
sont naturels et évidents très beaux
choix d'ouverture
petite position tranquille contre le roi
des complications
et maintenant comment on fait il est
caramel mou
ça ressemble un conseil du président ça
de Laurent Blanc
de jouer la petite finale
c'est tout lui ça et toi c'est du
contre-jeu avec tout il va faire tout à
deux Maxime pas de contre jeu
pas de contre je
pas de contre jeu tour à deux m'a l'air
tellement fort alors après il y a
peut-être un truc encore plus
encore plus mordant peut-être ça aussi
ça se regarde mais bon j'aurais peur de
ce genre de choses
et c'est vrai qu'on a donné un peu de
jeu alors ça doit pas être assez mais
bon
pourquoi pas tour à deux tout simplement
sans se casser la tête tour à deux jouer
et il dit un épaule non non non non tu
n'auras rien
voilà peut-être c'est Didier Deschamps
son nouvel entraîneur parce que là ça
ressemble à un coup c'est le coup Didier
Deschamps
c'est est-ce qu'on va en contre-attaque
pour marquer le troisième but ou est-ce
qu'on met en fait rentrer un défenseur
on fait plutôt rentrer un défenseur
technique Didier Deschamps
faut aussi ce qu'on va faire ok c'est 5
échecs peut-être
peut-être
ou pas
mal aussi pour faire que c'est 5 ans
suite et à 5 on a tout qui est bien là
tout qui a l'air bon
tout qui a l'air écrasant
par exemple
7 3D 6 c'est pas bon du tout ce que je
montre on reprend ah ouais c'est ça
c'est incroyable quand même ok donc
est-ce qu'il faut jouer ici qui est le
meilleur coup d'après la jauge c'est
cavalier 3 pour ainsi que ses 5 les
noirs doivent faire tourner et là on
pousse et ouais on est bien quand même
et surtout C3 attaquer un peu tout de la
famille on fait ça ça ça
ça attaque menace à fourchette et sur
roi des 6 vas-y que je te pousse le pion
et c'est terminado
donc tout ras de fou aussi
et
ça va être compliqué
ouais la gestion du temps de donner peau
toujours un petit peu approximative
bon après ça met la pression alors c'est
toujours pareil ça met une pression
dingue
3 jouer le meilleur coup il est précis
dans ses phases il a toujours été sa
tour était un de ces gros points forts à
Maxime dans ces phases un petit peu
technique
tu vois plein de tactique et le plan
technique il est très fort en fait c'est
vrai que sur le plan technique c'est
phases où il faut bien calculer deux
trois coups là il est très très fort
Maxime ça toujours été énorme point fort
tout petit déjà il était comme ça et
dans les phases tactiques aussi il est
très fort c'est ces deux gros points
forts
donc ça peut être Didier Deschamps
l'entraîneur pou je vous aime baby et
oui bien joué
bien joué de la part de Maxime on va
menacer aussi quai B4 parfois
et c'est 5 aussi et agenda
les deux coups
sont sympas
comment on fait est-ce que B4 est plus
précis ou alors poussé à 6 je sais pas
un des deux en tout cas
ok il pousse en fait
il pousse
et il joue que c'est 5 et la totale la
totale de la part de Maxime Vacher
lagraphe qui domine complètement cette
première partie les noirs sont
complètement immobilisés voyez ce fou
qui peut pas bouger parce qu'il y a le
pion toute façon fallait protéger avec
le roi enfin bon c'est un enfer c'est un
enfer à jouer cette tour qui est
complètement qui est derrière qui est
devant le pion donc ça va pas la tour
qui est derrière ici tout est bien placé
chez les Blancs est-ce que tout est mal
placé chez les Noirs ça ne va pas du
tout
c'est quoi ces points faibles pas de
points faibles chez Maxime machinagrave
cette déposition archi simples voilà un
petit peu c'est là où
Magnus peut faire la différence parfois
un peu sèche
typiquement il est pas si fort que
manuscrit pour pour gagner des finales
voilà
clairement
peut-être aussi un petit peu niveau
autant il a une connaissance incroyable
et finale autant les ouvertures il
connaît pas vous voyez il a pas une
culture générale qui est dingue
c'est à dire que se bad et voilà salut
parle moins que que qu'un Magnus qui a
peu touche à tout et c'est un gros
avantage de nos jours de pouvoir
surprendre en permanence et c'est vrai
que Maxime a moins cette capacité à
surprendre
voilà donc peut-être culture générale au
niveau des finales qui est présente
parce que ça intéresse beaucoup mais qui
est beaucoup moins présente au niveau
des ouvertures
c'est mon c'est mon avis
c'est la première édition de la High Cup
ouais c'est artificial intelligence
voilà pour célébrer tout ce qu'a fait
l'intelligence artificielle dans les
échecs et notamment alpha zéro dit Blue
qui était bon les ordinateurs ont
toujours un petit peu intelligence
artificielle
donc pour A7 jouer par les paumes
qui est prend des cinq doigts pas mal
mais on a certainement mieux il va
chercher mieux mvl c'est sûr
ouais non mais quand il est en forme au
top du top il est top 5 mondial voir top
2 il a été numéro demandé Maxime donc
qu'est-ce que je vous dis c'est aussi
lui qui décide peut-être aussi
parfois un point faible ça pourrait être
de se laisser
il me reste période de moins bien la
gérer
comme on l'a vu on l'a vu un moment
quand ça s'est mal passé aux candidats
après il a moins bien géré voyez la
deuxième partie quand elle s'est mal
passé il a moins bien géré la suite
c'est sûr est-ce que Magnus se remet
beaucoup mieux de ses mots cette période
par exemple
voilà ça aussi ça fait partie du des
talents d'un grand sportif Kebe 7 ans
que c'est joli kb7 qui a été des 8 ça
aussi ça fait partie des talents des
grands sportifs d'être capable
d'attaquer un cavalier de jouer Kylie
des 8 de gagner une pièce tout
simplement que c'est bien vu ce qu'est
B7 on est obligé de cavalier et qui ait
débité chèque arrive qui est C6 oh mais
moi je l'ai vu excuse-moi Yann quand
même
ouais je l'ai vu ça tourned 8 et
cavalier prend et cavalier des 4 c'est
PRIMOVE tout ça ouais non ça c'est fini
contre technicien comme quand même VL je
peux te dire que KFC G4 d'abord roi G3
et vas-y Carlie F5 et qui prend des cinq
au prochain coup tout ce que je veux
tour à trois non non non non non
monsieur népo miyachi ça ne passe pas il
fait quand il est F5 ouh là là bon bravo
bravo le son le son de final le son
technique à Yann des pomyashi et oui il
a appuyé sur son point faible
donc
qu'est-ce qu'on a je vais le
[Musique]
voilà je vais fermer ça et on a la
revanche dans
une dizaine de minutes
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé encore
on va faire un petit bilan on me l'avait
demandé de faire un petit bilan
je vais le faire le bilan de la partie
tu sais je fais jamais
donc pourquoi pas un petit bilan
je remets la bien la caméra
ouais là comme ça on voit bien
c'est mieux enfin c'est mieux bon alors
petit bilan de la partie tiens
on va voir analyse
non je peux faire un bilan moi
c'est pas ma partie donc
je pense pas que je puisse faire un
bilan de la partie je suis désolé
bon en tout cas il l'a bien il a rasé
c'est ça le bien il a rasé il a il mène
au zéro et il a les Noirs dans la
deuxième si il perd pas
super pas je vais vous montrer où il
arrive si il perd pas il redéfit demain
le roi Magnus le roi s'en couronne en
tout cas en ce moment à 18h dès demain
donc on va voir ça et en tout cas ça
fait plaisir ouais normalement Maxime il
est très très bon
il est très très bon là c'est un temps
et il nous fait nous a fait une Master
Class dans la première on verra si nepo
peut revenir ou pas on espère pas sur ce
pub
et on revient
et deuxième truc
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et je suis de retour pour ce match entre
Maxime Vacher Lagrave et
Yannis
d'avoir sa revanche contre
Magnus Carlson dans la grande finale de
demain à 18h il faudra battre deux fois
l'ogre norvégien mais déjà d'avoir la
revanche ça sera déjà beau
et on verra bien ça sera peut-être
demain attention ne vendons pas la peau
de l'ours
donc on va avoir cette deuxième partie
qui va bientôt recommencer on va faire
ça Maxime et Yann sont prêts Maxime va
voir les Noirs dans cette deuxième
partie il y a une éponyashi doivent
absolument
l'emporter les données sont très très
claires il lui a fait une Master Class
dans la première
et on attend la deuxième
avec une certaine impatience
on va voir les pots qui normalement joue
de 4 est fonce
est-ce qu'on aura une pétrole peut-être
de la part de Maxime probablement pas
une naydorf pas sûr pas sûr pas sûr
on sait pas c'est la magie de ce jeu
c'est qu'on ne sait jamais ce qui va se
passer
mais a priori avec Maxime on peut
deviner l'ouverture
certainement certainement une anef
pour notre plus grand plaisir c'est ça
donne toujours des parties très très
intéressantes
évidemment avec son style
son style si particulier
très tactique mais on voit comme il l'a
fait dans la partie aussi très technique
ouais le format de la grande finale ça
sera deux et demi gagnant suivi 2547 et
en cas de victoire de Maxime et bien la
revanche sera en un et demi gagnant
parce que d'une certaine façon Magnus
échoura dans le loser bracket
voilà ouais en gros la soirée de demain
est prise voilà c'est tout à fait ça tu
as très bien romain tu as très bien
résumé la situation la soirée de demain
vous la réservez 18h vendredi
4 parties déjà une victoire de Maxime et
un match en deux parties ça peut être ça
peut être très très beau
alors est-ce que ça reprend ou pas
qu'est-ce qu'il avait dit notre ami
notre ami dans le chat
il avait dit
que les parties la partie va reprendre
dans
la partie va reprendre
la partie normalement aurait dû
reprendre bon
la partie n'a pas reprise
c'est une certitude
ouais ouais il est il est très focus mvl
clairement
donc on attend ça reprenne
tranquillement
en l'occurrence c'est la technique c'est
aussi savoir calculer
des petites séquences
de manière très précise de deux trois
coups voilà c'est ça une bonne technique
aussi
donc effectivement
ça fait foie de bon tactiquement pour
avoir une bonne technique mais aussi
connaître plein de choses
à connaître plein de choses comme Maxime
connaît
il a étudié énormément
de
de finale et donc on va tourner chez qui
on voit une une offre dans ce petit
échiquier
et on rappelle le système anti-triche
qui est quand même très très bien fait
il y a deux caméras chez les joueurs
plus des logiciels qui évaluent des
performances de chaque joueur à chaque
fois
donc
on est quand même on est quand même
assez bien protégé
clairement et on voit une rrossolimo sur
échiquier KF3 KSI Nicolas rousselimo
genre français
du 19e siècle je crois
qui a inventé cette ouverture vous
pouvez 5 G6 rock fougères 7 Tourer
6 et il prend ses 6 des processus il
joue à 3 il y a des pommiers à chi ok il
a ajouté la cheville schnikov à son
arsenal Maxime Vacher Lagrave et donc là
il a vraiment envie de l'empêcher que H3
qui est 17 ok ça c'est très logique en
général on va faire le 5 cavalier F8 et
cavalier 6 et cahier des cadres et il
empêche et il fait le 5 directement
pour jouer vraiment contre ce fou de
case noire il joue des trois maintenant
cavaliers va certainement suivre pour
mettre le cavalier en Descartes
peut-être rock d'abord on va voir ce
qu'il va faire
et B3 ok B3 coûterait logique on empêche
des C4 on veut développer peut-être le
fou par là certainement pas mais en
général cahier des deux on veut aussi
attendre de voir
comment les Noirs se développent
non c'est pas une dragon
A4 OK
s'organiser de l'autre côté de
l'échiquier en jouant à 5 en pêchant B6
et thématique ce coup à 4
mais c'est un peu
une fois de plus un époque il prend pas
du tout de temps dans l'ouverture et qui
joue à toute blinde
on est on est dans la zone de bluff j'ai
l'impression
il joue 4 ok j'ai l'impression qu'il y a
des deux va venir là quand même ouais
pour histoire de reprendre avec le
cavalier un F3 et le problème c'est
Rossolimo c'est le fou de casse blanche
en C8 qui peut être très passif qui
bloque sur ses propres pions et donc ça
peut être complexe
en général on essaie peut-être de faire
faux aussi se fout des cinq voilà
j'allais vous en parler
pour se débarrasser de ce fou on est
content de se débarrasser de ce fou en
général c'est pas très grave c'est
possible pour ça que les Blancs jouent
H3 assez rapidement parce qu'on est
content des échanges même si on avait pu
en doubler c'est pas très grave
c'est pas si grave mais c'est surtout
soude casse blanche qui peut être
complètement dominée
alors maintenant comment on fait
bien je sais pas j'aime pas ce qu'il a
fait les pots
je trouve que B3 à 4 franchement
normalement à 4 quand on joue à 4 c'est
qu'on menace à 5
fou B2 jouer
ok certes ouais B6 tout à fait logique
en renforce le contrôle
et on demande aux blancs qu'est-ce que
tu veux faire
soit en B2 est quand même pas
extraordinaire normalement on essaie de
s'organiser pour faire fouet 4 dames des
deux et essayer de monter une attaque
sur le roi noir
on prépare le repas on entend des
casseroles un message je l'avais dit et
ouais ça prépare le repas à côté
bah voilà on va bientôt finir donc faut
bien
faut bien il faut bien que ça cuisine
sa cuisine de manière maladroite mais sa
cuisine
ça sent bon en tout cas je peux vous le
dire
alors à 5 jouer par les Blancs
en solimo est né en 1910
siècle donc c'est pas complètement faux
ouais c'était un peu à côté mais pas
complètement à côté
alors
5 pour mettre la pression ça c'est
logique Dame des 7 jouer
par mvl
o
je joue très vite aussi dans celle-là il
se laisse pas bluffer il connaît ses
schémas il est pas mal évidemment dès
qu'un cavaliers apparaît en C4 il est
mangé
et c'est pas évident de continuer avec
les Blancs ici
c'est pas évident du tout
si c'est pour qui se fait à manger ouais
possible dans sa chambre à Amsterdam
tour à 4 ouais pour poser une question
sur le cavalier en D4
[Rires]
attaque le cavalier en D4
et
suggère au noir de prendre une décision
alors soit B5
soit qui est épreuve 3 mais ça c'est un
bon coup j'aime bien ce coup pour le
coup
et oui c'est l'heure c'est l'heure de
manger ça y est à 20h15
c'est pas comme les autres soirs ce sera
une soirée qui va durer beaucoup moins
longtemps on marche pour demain déjà ce
soir moi je prévois c'est le repas de ce
soir et de demain soir parce que demain
soir il y aura pas le temps de manger
demain soir ça dure jusqu'au bout de la
nuit on le sent
avec deux Armageddon ça va être beau
on a hâte
oui c'est vrai que nous a donné son
menu ça a l'air sympa
nous donne pas ça à tout le chat s'il te
plaît merci
alors combien faire Maximilien il existe
il hésite pardon il existe oui il existe
aussi mais il hésite très clairement
entre B6 B5 qui peut s'avérer pas mal si
on arrive à organiser ces quatre par
exemple les prank va les prendre les C4
quelque chose comme ça
mais
si cette
option de faire qu'elle prend qu'elle
prend et peut-être on peut faire même
prendre aussi attention on peut faire
même prendre et ensuite ramener le
cavalier par là
ça parle très fort là à côté on va
demander de baisser le son quand même en
plus de faire tomber les casseroles
je pense que je parle plus fort
alors tour à 4
et réfléchis j'oublie ça mvl Tourer
et maintenant on va faire quelque chose
parce que ça peut s'avérer très faible
ici
ouais de deux armes demain ça peut être
beau
est-ce que le pion à blanc peut devenir
un problème non je pense pas
ouais le truc de la solimo en fait ouais
donc c'est pas lui qui l'a inventé mais
c'est lui qui l'a
qui l'a modernisé
certainement je sais pas j'invente là
mais attention ce pion c'est peut être
un gros problème qui avait le 4 est une
énorme menace pour Maxime
alors c'est en général ça porte les noms
des ouvertures c'est pas forcément celui
qui l'a inventé
mais c'est celui qui l'a popularisé
comment il va faire Maxime c'est pas si
évident là parce que ce pion c'est me
semble faible alors après vous allez
dans un futur mais lointain le pion à
blanc peut se retrouver faible mais bon
pour l'instant c'est pas du tout la
priorité qui avait les quatre est une
énorme menace et Maxime réfléchit pas
mal hein pour essayer de
pour essayer de
bien d'empêcher qui avait le cadre ce
qui vient de faire
ouais
je crois gg30b qui pleure tu devrais y
aller
j'ai pas de bébé qui pleure là je crois
pas en tout cas
popularisé c'est parce que j'ai dit
qui est un maillot du barça
les points
je ne crois pas
en fait quand on y pense
il faut calculer ça mais c'est pas très
long à calculer il faut prendre les deux
là qui fait mal
qui est un problème clairement
donc sur fouder 5 qu'est-ce qu'on fait
pas si évident en fait ok
intéressant ce qu'il a fait Maxime
comme le Magnus Quinn Gambit exactement
oui il y a quelques idées que j'ai même
un système
quasiment pas joué je pourrais vous
montrer sur le gambidam qui pourrait
être appelé c'est moi qui l'ai montré à
c'est moi qui ai trouvé de A à Z
d'ailleurs
après c'est pas un truc
je sais pas si je veux qui est mon nom à
côté de ce truc parce que c'est pas
c'est pas un truc d'attaquant si vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
truc B6 enfin bon bref
j'ai jamais joué
j'ai joué si j'ai joué un rapide et
Blitz peut-être
et en partie donc je crois pas
mettre le roux 74 qui me demande
si j'ai les enfants mais qui font pas
des cris de bébé
qui peuvent faire qui peuvent crier mais
qui sont pas des bébés
en tout cas
ça va pas content
alors x 3 attaque le pion et oui c'est
logique aussi je rate tout dans cette
partie on parle de bébé de nourriture là
effectivement d'Armageddon de deux
armaguaison demain donc là j'aurais
beaucoup plus de choses cavaliers aussi
ok joli on protège ce pion c'est tout
l'enjeu est-ce que c'est 4 c'est 4 et
envisageable fou point F3 mais pas
tellement dame prend on va peut-être
même revenir en Descartes jouer B4 et ça
va être confortable peut-être pour D8
aussi tout simplement
ton F ou Ton a et attention à ce pion ça
peut être délicat pour les
blancs donc ça c'est pas bon du tout
maintenant est-ce qu'on peut pas retirer
le cavalier
pour menacer ces quatre mais il y aurait
cavalier F4 je pense OK
ça c'est un petit peu embêtant
ouais c'est côté noir et c'est pas
ambitieux du tout
de suite ok il considérait c'est marrant
ça il considérait quoi
je sais pas je dois donner mon fout tous
les jours ici
je sais pas mais
ok il préfère jouer BK
j'aime pas les 4
non
mais bon ça donne des cases mais après
ce que c'est F5 ah oui il est beaucoup
plus ambitieux il veut garder ce fou et
ouvrir la grande diagonale ok c'est très
ambitieux il joue pas du tout pour la
nuit joue normalement il a bien raison
c'est ce qu'il faut faire
c'est ce qui veut faire il veut jouer
normalement pourquoi quand on joue bien
comme ça il y a pas de raison de
commencer à jouer pour faire nul à
forcer les échanges et ce genre de
choses
alors
pendant le passant je pense ça apporte
pas grand chose au blanc parce que
ne pas prendre en passant j'ai un coup
comme ça par exemple j'ai simplement
fait un J6 par exemple allez prendre à
me prendre la dame qui est très très
bien placé là alors j'ai 5 ensuite je
pense que les noirs sont complètement OK
en plus on peut essayer de punir
peut-être en faisant KF4 et H6 donc 4 et
pas bon
mais en tout cas il a joué sur F5 il a
joué puis on prend F6 en passant ça a
repris en F6 en passant très logique et
Dame des deux qui est aussi un coup
complètement standard
mais qui apparemment pas très bon est-ce
que F5 serait le coup pour essayer de
réveiller ce foodcast blanche F5 est
tellement normal donc là on fait [__]
en G7 a priori on reprend de quoi
du roi peut-être tout simplement non il
n'aime pas reprendre du roi de la dame
alors ah du cavalier
et maintenant comment fait-on
peut-être on prend tout simplement
et mieux que ça apparemment et si
cavalier prend on a même tout 8 qui est
assez confortable pour les Noirs il y a
pas trop de problèmes ici apparemment il
y avait un meilleur coup
au lieu de faire et ranger 5 je vais
regarder je vais tricher cavalier c'est
cette jolie pour menacer H6 et surcharge
des deux cavaliers
intéressant
ouais je vous montre mon ouverture à la
fin de la partie de ML je vous montre
mon cou
et merci pour le raid de radio Alice
je sais pas ce que c'est
merci
alors toi
par MV à Louise c'est le coup qu'on joue
avec la main toi à 8 on met la tour sur
la colonne vertes
archiologique un bon coup de solide
je vais vite c'est ce qu'on aime
il est bien il est bien Maxime il y a
pas de problème
pas de problème pour les noirs
ouais mais un peu mieux selon la jauge
ça fluctue entre
un léger très léger avantage noir et
[Musique]
l'égalité
mais pas de problème
pas de problème c'est sûr
il va où le Russe j'ai pas vu qu'il
était il a bougé ah oui turbo toilettes
pas de turbine toilette turbo toilette
c'est quand même admis une fois par
partie on a le droit
surtout qu'il y a un deuxième caméra qui
filme ouais bon ben c'est toujours
compliqué moi j'ose pas le faire ça je
me retiens
c'est OK de le faire une fois de temps
en temps voilà c'est ok c'est OK de le
faire c'est mieux c'est pas sur son
temps évidemment mais c'est OK de le
faire si on considère que c'est trop
répétitif il peut y avoir des sanctions
c'est toujours les règles sont pas hyper
vous voyez c'est pas hyper restrictif
non plus et donc c'est un petit peu vous
voyez ce que je veux dire
c'est un petit peu la prestation de
l'arbitre c'est fait en bon intelligence
avec l'arbitre
disons qu'on on met jamais une bulle
comme ça on va peut-être s'il fait ça
deux trois fois dans la partie va se
prendre
faut arrêter de faire ça
tourne alors ça
j'ai pas la f cette minute chacun c'est
pas mal pour Maxime est-ce que il va
jouer 5 je crois qu'à un moment il va
falloir faire F5 quand même
je sais pas ce que vous en pensez mais
ça paraît que le seul camp on peut
commencer par H6 pour faire F5 ensuite
mais bon pas sûr que
[Musique]
pas sûr qu'on doit vraiment s'embêter
faut prendre en gs7 et peut-être qu'on a
cette petite arnaque comme on l'avait
tout à l'heure sur kg 5 déjà au pire on
peut faire ça
pas mal pour essayer d'égaliser vous
voyez là je quitte là c'est ça et
évidemment le coup ambitieux qu'on a vu
pour faire des choses comme ça pour
menacer H6
mais pas si facile à avoir quoique si on
arrive dans la position ça paraît
beaucoup plus facile à voir est-ce qu'il
va faire
je pense qu'il va faire F5
alors F5 jouer par
mvl
ouais c'est gentil
pierre Angos alors c'est pas moi qui
décide au niveau moi je suis prêt à
commenter avec n'importe qui avec
beaucoup de monde en tout cas
Kevin compris bien évidemment
mais qui décide là ils ont décidé bon
vous le voyez à ces derniers temps on
est plutôt seul au commentaire donc
c'est chaise comme qui a la main
voilà on est plutôt seul je crois pour
des raisons évidentes
d'économie pas besoin de faire un master
en économie pour pour comprendre ça donc
oui c'est envisageable
tout est envisageable moi je le rappelle
je le rappelle je viens de chaise 24 du
groupe lehmanus et donc j'ai été très
très bien accueilli par cheesecom par
l'ensemble
par l'ensemble de chez com français et
étranger donc oui
tout est envisageable
mais pour l'instant la
en tout cas le truc qu'on fait c'est de
commenter seul que ça soit
quand c'est Kévin stouf ou moi-même
voilà
c'est comme ça
ils sont plusieurs mais c'est pas le
même marché non plus entre guillemets
c'est pas entre guillemets c'est pas le
même marché il a joué F5 mvl F5
et dame prend G7
et il est quand même il est quand même
bien Maxime tout simplement il est mieux
hein c'est sûr
que j'ai 5 ça coûte moins cher un seul
commentateur et oui bien vu forky 83 ça
dépend lequel on peut coûter très cher
aussi
c'est ça le truc
alors
si on est à deux
c'est pas une
c'était pas une réclamation que ce soit
n'importe qui pour dire ouais je prends
l'oseille du du CO commentateur et je
fais ça tout seul
donc voilà
c'est pas moi je gagne pas plus que je
sois je préfère être à deux en vrai mais
c'est bien tout seul aussi je crois je
prends du plaisir il y a pas de problème
donc j'aime bien les deux donc il y a
aucun souci à ce niveau-là
mais voilà je suis pas payé plus je
préfère rassurer tout le monde parce que
il va venir et qui va dire que je suis
un affreux capitaliste
esclavagiste et tout ça non non
ça se passe c'est le même montant
effectivement ça coûte moins cher à
chaise comme
c'est une évidence
donc il est bien Maxime c'est à peu près
égal c'est vrai qu'après H6 on voit
vraiment pas le problème cavalier F3 on
va encaisser ici en F3 puis on prend et
pourquoi on serait moins bien ici la
jauge ça me plaît pas aimer alors ça ça
me ça me surprend un petit peu
je pense qu'elle va changer d'avis quand
même il y a un petit problème sur H6 si
je fais en H7 il se passe quoi peut-être
pour trois que je laisse comme ça pour
essayer de doubler
peut-être légère avantages blancs mais
bon H6 cavalier F3 joué par mvl
je sais pas vas-y balançoire je sais
honnêtement je sais pas combien les
autres sont payés
à l'époque je savais chaise 24
c'est moi qui proposait les choses aux
différents streamers aux différents
commentateurs
donc je peux vous donner les tarifs de
l'époque même si je vais pas le faire
parce que je sais pas c'est pas moi de
le dire
mais là je n'ai absolument aucune idée
de combien
les gens sont payés
c'est la tête du client
je sais pas c'est une ego
c'est négo comme ça se fait dans tous
les jobs
après je pense qu'ils essayent de
[Musique]
j'en sais rien en plus
lycée moi c'est ce que j'essaie de faire
en gros à chass24 tout le monde était à
peu près payé pareil
pour pas qu'il y ait de tous les choses
se sachent se savent je sache
sur ce sale et donc voilà vous essayez
de faire un truc où personne va trop
râler
on essaie de garder tout le monde
content si ça c'est ça le concept
c'était le mien en tout cas vous F3 et
j'ai 5 pour protéger ce pion ok
peut-être j'ai quatre aussi ouvrir le
roi pas mal joué de la part de Maxime
enfin intéressant en tout cas il est un
peu moins bien selon la chose qui est
quand même assez surprenant peut-être
cette faiblesse des pions mais quand
même ça se tient ça c'est sûr
allez
allez Maxime il faut tenir cette finale
il a une minute trente de moins mais
c'est pas très grave et si tient cette
fille à sa revanche contre manuscrit
logique pour faire Tourer un il joue sa
chance crânement aussi notre ami nepo
est-ce qu'on va faire un G4 à un moment
ou pas cet enfant maintenant de faire un
petit G4 non
puis on prend puis on prend peut-être
tourgé trois là
je prends la tour G3 a l'air un peu
pénible quand même
tour 3
alors
non je sais pas comment je sais pas
je sais pas honnêtement
on va voir ce qu'il va faire il faut se
dépêcher il a peur de Maxime devin
contre 4,40 pas ce pas passé en dessous
des deux une ou deux minutes là
mais réfléchis Maxime il veut régler ses
problèmes tout de suite et maintenant
oui alors j'ai mis que ça veut dire ça
veut dire grand maître international
pour celui qui nous rejoignait je pense
qu'il y avait pas suivi de stream j'ai 4
n'est pas bon d'après la jauge ok à
cause de pions prend mais si je fais
tout reprendre à bord dame prend c'est
ça
ah peut-être puis on prend et sur puis
on prend il n'aime pas du tout donc faut
faire la puis on prend puis on prend je
vais faire dame prendre un G2
peut-être qu'il y a un coup de Trafalgar
à la tour F6 sur G6 non c'est quoi le
coup je vais tricher c'est tout F3 le
coup ton F3 pour menacer tour G3 et sur
dmg2 il y a tout reprend E3 ok alors ce
qu'il va faire et sur j'ai 4 et je crois
je suis un tempo et c'est pas mal joué
parce que c'est vrai que la tour va
venir en G1 si on prend H3 ou on prend
un F3 G4 est une faute d'après la jauge
et Maxime qui passe en dessous des deux
minutes là pour l'instant il a été
impérial mais la petit coup de mou pour
maxi se lève oh non mais il infernal il
a fait un
police
le courtois you met le petit prince et
le pourquoi je connais pas ce dentiste
je plaisante ça ça va venir t'inquiète
2020 avant 2026 ça sort le cours de chez
sébble vous inquiétez pas j'ai H5 est
une faute d'après la jauge mais c'est
vrai que là il a un peu ouvert pour pour
les blancs en fait les blancs
qui peut arriver tout heureux me semble
être un très bon coup ici pour faire ton
point à 8 mais c'est pas bon du tout
d'après la jauge c'est quoi le coup là
le bon coup après H5 c'est Dame 2 et un
gros avantage blanc parce que sur tout
il y a dame j'ai 5
clou en truc ok c'est quand même assez
fin comme truc donc H5 dames 2 et
surtout reprend E3 dame prend un 3 et
c'est un avantage décisif pour les
blancs d'après la jauge menace dame 6
menace tours géant menace tout plein de
choses et je tourne un tempo
était quand même le coup humain le
premier coup qui me venait on a une tour
sur une couronne fermée on essaie de
l'activer c'est tout à fait logique
non les joueurs ne voient pas la jauge
évidemment que non que les joueurs
voient pas la jauge sinon ça serait de
la triche si voilà je sais de la triche
ah ouais non là on peut pas
MG5 et oui bien joué meilleur coup
d'après d'après l'ordi
ah oui j'ai bien moi aussi je l'attends
mon cours sur hsnikov je l'attends si
vous pouvez faire tout seul ça m'arrange
si j'étais un peu moins paresseux
non
c'est pas ce qu'il a mais bon
c'est pas ce qu'il a mais en tout cas
ça stresse hein les échecs donc c'est
vrai que moi par exemple typiquement
[Musique]
je vais plus aux toilettes quand je
quand je joue quand je joue pas à cause
du stress
c'est évident
MG5 coup de clou à jordaneux est-ce
qu'on peut gagner ce genre de finale la
meude est pas un bon coup on reprend je
voulais faire dame prend pour ça ça peut
être délicat quand même pour les Noirs
parce que tout le 5 peut arriver
regardez on attaque tout alors une
mauvaise structure mais les pions sont
vraiment très faibles alors on peut
encaisser ici mais rouage 2 va venir
c'est pas grand chose
alors dame G5 dame 2 tours E3 et joue ça
incroyable vous voyez hein lui aussi il
est pas il est moins bon que la jauge
c'est chaud c'est chaud pour Maxime avec
moins d'une minute quand même
c'est pas moi qui décide ma tel roux 74
qui on voit qui on voit pas tu as chopé
le mauvais interlocuteur
je suis commentateur ici
alors 3 c'est chaud
c'est une gaffe d'après la jauge
pourquoi c'est une gaffe encore se
moquer de moi échec
pas bon
c'est quoi le coup je sais pas
échec me semble tellement naturel c'est
roi géant le coup énorme et sur dame
proche 3 c'est 5 il y a pas un cas où il
est surpris on prend H3 jours roi H2 et
tour géant on a l'attaque roi juin il y
a pas un monde où j'ai un évidemment il
a joué dame G6
il fallait faire roi G7 tours F7 est une
gaffe MG6 3 F8 pourquoi c'est une gaffe
damage 6 maintenant si roi G8 mats et si
ton G7 qui va être joué évidemment
dame j'ai 6 damage 6 tours G7 le coup
c'est
échec par là ouais 7 on peut passer
maintenant 2 lame 6,8 3G 8
c'est quoi le truc je comprends pas dame
six tour F7 et F4 maintenant ou ça gagne
ça gagne mais c'est hyper dur
priorité au direct évidemment il a une
40 contre 40 secondes
Maxime et agrafe dans le dur mais c'est
hyper dur à trouver pour les blancs dans
les variantes c'est quasi impossible
échec
échec et dame prend mais alors allez
trouver allez trouver ça et ça ça c'est
la bonne variante md6 3 G8 et d'un
Français 5 ah non c'est ma tendu après
mais non qu'est-ce qu'il me raconte là
non c'est pas évident du tout
il réfléchit beaucoup il y a des pots
contre 45 secondes je sais même pas
j'arrive j'ai la ligne de l'ordi sous
les yeux je vois même pas je comprends
même pas ce que c'est le bon coup parce
qu'il répète beaucoup leur dit je joue
ça ça
et là il rejoue ça
et sur ça il rejoue ça et sur ça il fait
ça donc c'est F4 le coup c'est hyper dur
F4 dernier six échecs jouer par Yann les
pomyachi
c'est pas bon
c'est pas bon d'après la jauge
j'ai 7 et le bon coup
j'ai essayé de jouer pour mvl 34
secondes
et tout aussi
toi aussi il faut faire d'imprimer
est-ce que ça me prend H3 père d'un
prince 3 pairs parce que vous jouez
d'après F2 il faut des nerfs d'acier
pour jouer dame prend F2 parce que
tourgé 6 3 H7 tourage 6 3 G7 il y a pas
de maths il faut que Maxime voit
d'un prime F2 c'est hyper dur
c'est hyper dur il a joué un bref de
bravo Maxime oh là là très fort il y a
pas de maths
il y a pas de maths tourgé 6 rois 7 tour
H6 3 G7
il peut pas répéter et ça a l'air
gagnant maintenant dame G6 3 F8 échecs 7
maintenant c'est même gagnant pour les
Noirs même j'ai 5 il y aura un dernier
coup à trouver je pense là c'est la
position de l'échiquier tourage 6 ouais
il joue tout à je suis trop recette dame
G5 là d'après la jauge roi des si c'est
le meilleur
ROI des si c'est le meilleur ROI des si
c'est joué quel talent quel talent
tourner 8 3 C7 dame D8 qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire la musique 3e
alors là c'est trop
mais il est obligé de faire un échec de
toute façon
et ça c'est incroyable incroyable ce qui
se passe mais Maxime va chez elle est en
train de se qualifier
pour
la grande finale face à manuscrit
pas fini mais
pas fini mais quasi
quasi fini comment il fait là il
réfléchit 8 secondes
8 secondes dame début d'échec jouer roi
le 5 et gagnant ici d'après la jauge
mais bon et cinq jouets mais quel talent
est-ce que se perdait certainement parce
qu'il est tourage 6 ouais
donc c'était pas si c'était obligé en
fait tout revu 3 F4 Dame des 6 trois
points F3 dame français 6 3 G3 et
maintenant les noirs sont gagnants
les noirs sont complètement gagnants en
Dame des six F4 et Maxime qui va en
finir avec cette partie Dame des 6 F4
bravo c'est ma tante trois coups c'est
matin 3 coups d'après la jauge
incroyable victoire de Maxime va chier
Lagrave 2-0 quel talent mais quel talent
il a été très bon il afflué un coup de
mou hein quand même à l'approche du Jane
note et vous voyez les soulager et il
importe 2 à 0 face à Yann et pomyachi et
qu'est-ce qui se passe du coup il aura
l'honneur
de défier
manuscarsen dans la grande finale bravo
à lui il faudra qu'il batte deux fois
dès demain Magnus Carlsen ça sera pas
facile évidemment mais grande
performance
dans cette première partie d'abord très
technique et dans cette deuxième partie
où il y a une aire solide et c'est vrai
qu'il a trouvé ce dame prime F2 je vois
dans le chat très impressionné par d'un
point F2 ouais c'était quand même
c'était quand même nerdacier là avec 5
secondes à la pendule
bravo Maxime très très bien joué
vraiment très impressionnant mvl
aujourd'hui comme tous les autres jours
du reste il part du zoom du coup on va
partir de la nous aussi et on le
rappelle Maxime va chez Lagrave demain
18h face à Magnus Carlsen arrêtez tout
annuler tout quatre parties c'est 4 4
parties de haut vol comme hier
certainement peut-être un Armageddon
peut-être pas on sait pas ce qui va se
passer mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est qu'on va voir
des échecs de très très haut niveau
donc voilà il me reste plus qu'à vous
donner rendez-vous même jour même heure
non
le jour différent demain demain vendredi
même heure un peu avant 18h
18h moins 10 pour la grande finale de
cette artificielle intelligence Cup
entre Maxime et manuscarsen manus Carson
aura droit à l'erreur maxime n'a plus
droit à l'erreur mais si Maxime venait à
l'emporter dans le premier match on
aurait un deuxième match et ça peut être
ça peut être magnifique
ah j'ai oublié de montrer mon ouverture
c'est tout moi ça
et je monte mon ouverture
je monte mon ouverture j'avais promis
c'est ça mon ouverture
qui pourrait porter mon nom
4 rock E3 B6
la pointe étant sur food étroit puis on
prend ces quatre vous prend ces quatre
fois si ça c'est vraiment ma variante de
faire fois 6 c'est réglé noir jouer
d'habitude avec des choses avec fou B7
ou puis on prend un fou B7
et voilà ça c'est vraiment ma ligne
c'est moi qui l'ai inventé et c'est la
ligne que Ding a joué
que Magnus Carlson a joué contre Ding
pour la première fois à dans un dans une
partie de Grand Maître bon là c'était
une partie de grand grand maître de top
grand maître entre le numéro 1 le numéro
de mondial sur ce
je vous
remercie infiniment
de m'avoir suivi je vous donne
rendez-vous dès demain pour évidemment
ce dernier jour mais qui sera
certainement le meilleur c'est dur à
battre Camille c'était quand même assez
intense il faut deux matchs comme hier
et voilà comme ça on aura encore plus
d'intensité enfin en tout cas on a hâte
de voir ce qui va se passer avec un
Maxime chez Lagrave complètement
olympique
sur ce une excellente fin de soirée à
tout le monde pour des forces pour
demain et à demain ciao ciao
[Musique]